- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
Je vous indique
que j'ai reçu aujourd'hui,
à 14h30, une motion
de censure déposée
par madame Mathilde Panot,
monsieur Boris Vallaud,
madame Cyrielle Chatelain,
monsieur André Chassaigne,
et 146 membres
de l'Assemblée nationale,
en application
de l'article 49 alinéa 2
de la Constitution.
En application
de l'article 153
de notre règlement,
il est pris acte
de ce dépôt.
La motion de censure
va être notifiée
au gouvernement et affichée.
La date et l'heure
de la discussion
de la motion seront fixées
par la conférence
des présidents que je réunirai.
L'ordre du jour
appelle la déclaration
du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat,
au titre de l'article 50
de la Constitution.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
L'Assemblée nationale
acclame Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs les députés.
Le propre
de toute société humaine,
c'est de regarder
en face l'avenir
qui se dessine
devant elle, interroger
son modèle, puiser en soi
les ressources suffisantes
pour corriger ce qui doit
l'être, construire
les bonnes solutions.
Une société
ne se perd jamais
quand elle cherche à avancer.
Une société
ne se perd jamais
quand elle doute.
Elle perd quand le doute
l'emporte
sur tout le reste,
quand le doute glace,
quand il fige,
quand il conduit à douter
non pas de l'avenir
qui se dessine
mais à douter de soi-même,
de ses forces,
de ses capacités.
Je suis né...
L'Assemblée nationale
acclame Gabriel Attal.
Je suis né en 1989,
l'année du bicentenaire
de la Révolution.
Une année 89, où on a cru
que la démocratie libérale
et le progrès universel
triompheraient
par eux-mêmes.
Ma génération a vu
l'inverse se produire.
Notre génération,
partout dans le monde,
voit son monde chamboulé
plus fortement
encore que toute autre avant elle.
Elle est en proie au doute.
Doute sur l'avenir
de sa planète, doute
sur son identité,
doute ici, en France,
sur qui nous sommes,
comme peuple
et comme nation.
Doute sur notre modèle
social,
sur le service public,
sur notre démocratie.
Notre responsabilité,
celle de chacune
et chacun d'entre nous,
c'est de puiser
en nous la force
d'identifier
tous les ressorts
pour les surpasser.
Si nous sommes engagés
par-delà
nos divergences,
c'est que nous avons
un point commun partagé
par des dizaines
de millions
de nos concitoyens,
nous voyons davantage
de raisons d'espérer
que de douter.
C'est parce que
nous sommes prêts
à affronter pour avancer,
affronter
pour avancer.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés...
Des députés acclament
Gabriel Attal.
En m'exprimant
face à vous,
c'est en réalité
à chaque citoyen
de notre pays que je m'adresse.
A travers vous,
c'est à chacun
de nos concitoyens
que je veux le dire,
nous ne sommes pas n'importe
quel pays.
La France n'a jamais
été, n'est pas,
et ne sera jamais
une nation qui subit
ni aujourd'hui, ni demain.
...
Dans les pires
moments de doute,
de désarroi, de désunion,
elle a montré
sa solidité,
son supplément d'âme,
qui fait d'elle une nation
à nulle autre pareille.
En cette année 2024,
nous commémorons
les 80 ans du Débarquement,
la libération
de la France,
le soutien à des Français
qui n'avait jamais
cessé de croire
en elle.
Nous allons ouvrir
les portes de Notre-Dame
de Paris alors que l'image
des flammes restent vives
dans les yeux des Français.
En cette année 2024,
nous accueillerons
le monde, un monde bouleversé,
un monde divisé.
Oui, nous accueillerons
le monde à l'occasion
des Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques.
La France rime avec puissance.
La France est un repère,
un idéal,
un patrimoine millénaire.
C'est un héritage
moral, la nation
d'un modèle social envié
dans le monde entier.
La France...
La France, c'est le pays
de la création
que nous soutenons.
Et qui nous fait rayonner.
C'est la patrie
de la recherche à laquelle
nous donnons des moyens
sans précédent.
C'est la nation
de l'innovation
qui construit
le monde de demain,
de 2030.
La France,
ce sont nos jeunes qui osent
et qui se lancent.
La France,
ce sont nos familles
et toutes ces mères
célibataires
qui se battent,
qui ne lâchent jamais rien.
Ce sont nos soignants,
nos professeurs,
nos forces de l'ordre,
tous nos agents publics,
nos militaires
qui s'engagent
pour quelque chose
qui les dépasse.
Ce sont nos artisans
qui font rayonner
nos savoir-faire,
nos agriculteurs,
nos pêcheurs
qui travaillent matin midi
et soir pour nous nourrir...
Ce sont nos élus
locaux,
et je suis l'un
des leurs depuis 10 ans,
qui s'engagent
et donne corps et âme
pour leur territoire,
ce sont nos associations,
nos bénévoles...
C'est 68 millions
de Français de l'Hexagone
et de l'outre-mer
qui n'ont pas fini
de nous surprendre.
Dans un monde
où tout s'accélère,
où tout se transforme,
je refuse
avec eux que notre identité
puisse
se diluer ou se dissoudre.
La France a son rang
à tenir, sa voix
à faire entendre,
sa singularité à tenir,
sa voix à faire entendre,
sa singularité
à imposer.
Nous avons une fierté
française à maintenir.
Une fierté européenne
à consolider.
Affronter pour avancer.
Les difficultés économiques,
les bouleversements climatiques,
démographiques,
géopolitiques,
ils ne nous conduiront
jamais
à nous perdre.
Cela ne signifie pas la fin
de tout,
mais le passage
d'un monde à l'autre.
Un passage difficile,
un passage douloureux,
inquiétant à bien
des égards,
mais un passage
que nous réussirons,
j'en suis intimement convaincu.
A ceux qui veulent y voir
notre disparition,
j'y vois notre renaissance.
Nous avons une identité
et des valeurs.
A ceux qui veulent
y voir un triangle
des Bermudes,
j'y vois notre savoir,
nous savons
où nous voulons aller,
et nous y arriverons.
A ceux qui veulent
y voir une perte
de boussole, j'y vois
une détermination
car j'ai confiance.
J'ai confiance
car je connais les obstacles
que nous avons franchis
et les tabous
que nous avons levés.
J'ai confiance
parce que je connais
les Français, leur énergie,
leur volonté,
leur créativité...
J'ai confiance
parce que face aux épreuves,
aux inquiétudes
et aux crises,
notre pays s'est toujours relevé.
L'épidémie de Covid a mis
à jour bon nombre
de fractures
dans notre société,
elle a poussé
notre modèle social
dans ses retranchements
mais notre pays
a tenu et nous avons protégé
nos concitoyens beaucoup mieux
que beaucoup d'autres l'ont fait.
Le dérèglement
climatique nous frappe
plus dur, plus fort, plus souvent.
Notre pays agit
avec force et jamais
dans son histoire
les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre n'ont baissé
aussi rapidement
que l'an dernier.
La guerre en Ukraine
a ébranlé l'Europe.
Elle a détruit le rêve
d'une paix éternelle
sur notre continent.
Elle nous a rappelé
durement
que la démocratie
était fragile
et la liberté, un idéal
toujours à défendre.
Notre pays,
notre Europe, ont montré
le visage
de la détermination face
à l'agresseur
et sa solidarité
pour le peuple ukrainien.
L'attaque terroriste
monstrueuse
en Israël et la guerre
au Proche-Orient
ont ravivé des plaies,
des maux
jusque dans notre société.
Notre pays a su
se dresser et répondre
par le refus
de la haine et l'unité.
La crise énergétique,
l'inflation,
la menace terroriste,
les crises
se superposent et s'additionnent.
Elles n'offrent
aucune solution miraculeuse.
Méthodiquement,
avec les Français,
nous y répondrons.
Pour beaucoup
de Français, l'avenir
est davantage une crainte
qu'une promesse.
Encore trop de Français
ont le sentiment
de perdre le contrôle
de leur propre vie.
Avec le président
de la République,
avec mon gouvernement,
je ne m'y résous pas,
je ne m'y résoudrai jamais.
Pour tous les Français,
nous allons affronter
pour avancer.
Pas par des belles paroles,
de grands actes
et de beaux discours,
mais par des actes rapides,
concrets, de nouveaux
changements
dans leur vie et sur le terrain!
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
l'identité même
de cette majorité,
de ce gouvernement,
c'est de reconquérir
notre souveraineté française
et européenne.
Notre promesse
aux Français est claire.
Oui, nous voulons
reprendre notre destin
en main en ouvrant
une nouvelle page
de cette conquête,
nous pouvons
nous appuyer sur un bilan
concret, tangible
et solide.
En 2017, ma génération
n'avait connu
que la désindustrialisation
qui semblait inéluctable.
Le chômage de masse
qui s'ancrait, l'Europe
qui se désunissait,
la transition écologique
qui rimait avec nécessité
plus qu'avec réalité.
En 2017, la souveraineté
de la France
et de l'Europe
étaient pour beaucoup
un pensée.
Pour certains,
il s'agissait d'un gros mot.
Nous avons assumé.
Nous avons aussi
assumé d'en faire
la matrice de notre action.
Nous avons agi!
Nous avons engagé
une action résolue
pour la souveraineté
économique
avec pour la première
fois le retour
de l'industrie sur notre sol,
n'en déplaise
aux Cassandre!
N'en déplaise
aux Cassandre,
il y a désormais
plus d'usines qui ouvrent
que d'usines
qui ferment en France,
plus d'emplois
industriels
qui sont créés
que d'emplois industriels
qui sont détruits en France.
Ce n'était pas arrivé
depuis 30 ans!
Notre taux de chômage
est descendu
à un niveau jamais
atteint depuis 25 ans.
Pour la 25e année
consécutive,
notre pays
est le plus attractif d'Europe
pour les investissements
étrangers!
Nous avons engagé
des moyens
contre le réchauffement
climatique
et pour la planification
écologique inédite
dans le monde
et une stratégie énergétique
pour une énergie
plus souveraine
et plus durable.
Nous avons engagé
une action résolue
pour la souveraineté
de nos frontières
avec une loi
immigration et impacté
ainsi l'immigration
au niveau européen,
enfin protecteur de notre pays.
Nous avons engagé
une action résolue
pour que chaque Française,
chaque Français,
puisse garder le contrôle
de sa propre vie,
qu'il ne soit jamais
entravé, assigné
à résidence
et nous avons engagé
une action
pour la souveraineté agricole
de notre pays.
Depuis le début
de cette intervention,
je dis
que notre agriculture
est une force.
Pas seulement
parce qu'elle nous alimente,
mais parce
qu'elle constitue
un des fondements
de notre identité
et de nos traditions.
Nos agriculteurs incarnent
des valeurs fondamentales.
Lorsqu'ils sont bridés,
ça fragilise l'ensemble
de la société.
Je pense au travail,
et à la liberté d'entreprendre.
Notre agriculture
est une force
et une fierté.
Il y a, et il doit y avoir,
une exception agricole française!
Je suis lucide.
Je suis lucide face
à l'empilement
des normes, face
aux décisions qui tombent
d'en haut.
L'agriculture doute
et elle attend
des réponses et des solutions.
Nous serons
au rendez-vous
sans aucune ambiguïté.
Madame la présidente...
Devant vous, je prends
la parole, conscient
de l'ampleur de la tâche
à accomplir.
Je veux m'adresser
à tous les Français,
qui doutent, qui espèrent,
qui écoutent
et qui n'y croient plus.
Je veux m'adresser
aux Français
de la classe moyenne
au rendez-vous
de leurs responsabilités,
qui ne se plaignent
pas et qui ont le sentiment
de subir.
A ces Français
qui ont le sentiment
d'avoir tous les devoirs
quand d'autres
ont tous les droits!
A ces Français
qui ont parfois le sentiment
que leur propre
pays s'éloigne,
qu'ils n'y ont plus vraiment
leur place
alors qu'ils ont le coeur battant.
A ces Français trop riches
pour bénéficier
des aides
mais pas assez
pour ne pas
en bénéficier,
qui ont le sentiment
que les décisions
se prennent
sans eux et bénéficient
toujours aux mêmes personnes.
A ces Français
qui ont parfois l'impression
de vivre dans une France
archipel
dont les ponts
sont sur le point
de rompre.
A ces Français
qui espèrent au fond d'eux
qu'on arrivera à les réunir.
Ils ne demandent
qu'à pouvoir vivre
de leur travail,
éduquer leurs enfants,
se soigner et vivre en sécurité!
Je les entends.
Comme la majorité
oeuvre depuis 2017,
je veux contribuer
à leur répondre.
Je le veux avec d'autant
plus de détermination
que je sais le risque
pour eux serait
de céder à des sirènes
qui ne conduiraient qu'au chaos,
et à l'effondrement.
Pendant que nous agissons,
certains guettent,
entretiennent les colères
et espérant récolter
les fruits.
Le défi est immense.
J'ai bien
conscience
que nous ne pourrons pas
le relever seuls
avec les ministres
que je remercie
pour l'engagement sans faille.
J'ai bien conscience
aussi du message
très clair exprimé
par les Français
en 2022.
Nous avons une majorité
que je salue,
à qui je veux dire
ma confiance,
ma fidélité,
mais qui est relative.
Les Français veulent
que nous cessions
les querelles de principes
pour échanger,
pour agir ensemble.
Sur bien des textes,
nous y sommes parvenu.
Je le dis à la majorité
et aux oppositions,
nous avons la France en partage.
Nous avons un devoir
commun de transcender
les clivages,
les désaccords
et les divisions
pour oeuvrer au service
des Français.
Evidemment,
nous ne serons pas d'accord
sur tout.
Nous nous opposerons
dans cet hémicycle
et ailleurs.
Je ne renoncerai
jamais à dialoguer.
Ma porte sera toujours ouverte.
A travers vous,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés
des oppositions,
ce sont les voix
de millions de Français
qui s'expriment
même
si je ne suis pas
convaincu
que des millions de Français
veuillent
qu'on cherche
à couvrir la voix
de son interlocuteur
lorsqu'il parle
à l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est aussi cela,
la méthode
que je veux pour mon gouvernement.
Respectez notre Parlement,
je m'y engage.
J'en serai le garant.
Ma méthode a toujours été la même.
Chaque Français
porte une vérité
sur notre pays.
Nous devons l'écouter
et y répondre.
Forces politiques, élu local,
j'ai toujours échangé
avec lucidité.
Je veux chercher
à faire résonner
les mots de nos concitoyens,
répondre
à leurs inquiétudes
et porter
leurs espoirs.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
ma priorité est claire:
favoriser
le travail
pour que ceux qui en sont éloignés
s'en rapprochent,
soutenir les personnes
qui sont toujours
au rendez-vous
de la responsabilité.
Mon cap est clair.
C'est celui
de la souveraineté
et de l'indépendance
à l'échelle individuelle,
nationale et européenne.
Ma méthode est claire.
Elle reste la même.
Dire les choses.
Dire la vérité même
quand ça fait mal,
même quand ça nous conduit
à remettre
en cause de décision.
Dire la vérité et agir, vraiment,
agir maintenant.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, parler
aux Français, c'est,
au fond, entendre
quatre appels à l'action.
Pour l'autorité
et le civisme, le respect
des droits
et devoirs, partout
et pour tous.
Pour un environnement
plus respirable,
partout et pour tous.
Je veux l'affirmer.
Nous n'avons pas renoncé.
Nous n'avons pas renoncé
aux grandes conquêtes
et à la création
de droits nouveaux.
Pour le travail,
pour nos services publics,
pour le rétablissement
de l'autorité
dans la société,
pour la transition écologique,
nous partons d'un bilan solide.
Derrière le cap fixé
par le président
de la République,
nous avons multiplié
les actions et les réformes.
Je veux rendre hommage à l'action
déterminante d'Edouard Philippe,
Jean Castex,
et Elisabeth Borne,
dont le sens de l'Etat
et la détermination
sont des exemples.
Je veux rendre hommage
à la majorité toujours mobilisée
pour améliorer
le quotidien des Français.
Je veux saluer tous
les parlementaires
qui ont accepté de sortir
des logiques partisanes
pour permettre l'adoption
de nombreux textes.
Aujourd'hui, les résultats
sont présents.
Depuis 2017,
nous avons montré
que le chômage
de masse
n'était pas
une fatalité,
nous avons engagé
des réformes fortes
qui avaient été
trop longtemps repoussées,
nous avons pris
les ordonnances travail
dès le début du premier
quinquennat,
nous avons mené une réforme
de l'assurance-chômage,
une réforme
de l'apprentissage,
des retraites,
nous avons lancé le contrat
d'engagement jeune,
nous avons baissé
les impôts
et les charges,
et engagé une réforme majeure
du lycée professionnel.
Notre industrie revient.
Nous avons le cap
du million d'emplois
en vue.
Depuis 2017,
nous avons agi massivement
pour le service public,
pour notre santé,
avec les 19 milliards
d'euros du Ségur
de la santé,
et une revalorisation historique
des soignants,
de l'augmentation
des places en études de médecine.
Nous avons engagé
des transformations majeures
à l'école pour l'égalité
des chances.
Je pense au dédoublement
des classes
ou à l'augmentation du salaire
des enseignants,
la plus forte depuis 30 ans.
Pour notre sécurité,
nous avons investi
comme jamais par le passé.
10.000 postes
de policiers et gendarmes
ont été créés
pendant le premier quinquennat.
8500 pendant celui-ci.
Nous avons lancé
la création de 238 brigades
de gendarmerie nouvelles.
La sécurité doit
être pour tous,
y compris
dans la ruralité
et dans les petites villes.
Depuis 2017,
pour la planète,
nous avons préféré,
aux grands mots,
les vrais actes.
Nous agissons.
Avant 2017, les émissions
de gaz à effet
de serre ont baissé
de moitié par rapport
au premier quinquennat.
L'année dernière,
elles ont baissé
de près de 50%.
C'est notre crédit sur l'action.
Conformément à l'engagement
du président
de la République,
nous avons une stratégie complète
de planification écologique.
Nous nous donnons
les moyens de réussir
et nous investissons 40
milliards d'euros
pour la transition écologique.
Nous avons beaucoup
fait, mais il reste
encore du chemin.
Avec mon gouvernement,
je suis prêt,
je suis déterminé.
Nous devons répondre
aux inquiétudes
de la classe moyenne
et faire en sorte
que les personnes
qui vont travailler
plus dignement de leur travail
gagnent toujours
plus que ceux qui ne
travaillent pas.
Nous devons répondre
aux défis des emplois
non pourvus.
Il est incompréhensible
que le chômage reste
à ce niveau
alors qu'il y a tant d'entreprises
et de filières qui cherchent
à recruter partout
sur le territoire national.
Nous avons en France un paradoxe.
Nous avons un salaire minimum
nettement supérieur
à celui de nos voisins.
Nous en sommes fiers.
Mais nous avons une part
de nos travailleurs proche
du SMIC, beaucoup
plus importante
que nos voisins.
C'est un problème.
Nous agirons
résolument
pour que les branches
professionnelles
qui continuent
à rémunérer en dessous
du SMIC remontent
ces rémunérations.
C'était le cas d'une
soixantaine d'entre
elles l'été dernier.
Grâce à la mobilisation,
nous étions descendus
à une trentaine à la fin
de l'année 2023.
La revalorisation du SMIC
au 1er janvier dernier
en a fait redescendre
une partie
en dessous du SMIC.
Je demande de poursuivre
et amplifier
la mobilisation
pour des résultats rapides.
Je n'exclus aucune mesure
pour y parvenir.
Ensuite, nous devons
faire évoluer
un système
qui nous a conduits,
je le disais
il y a un instant,
depuis des décennies,
à concentrer
nos aides et nos exonérations
au niveau
du SMIC.
Pour augmenter
de 100 euros le revenu
d'un employé au SMIC,
l'employeur doit déployer
238 euros de plus.
Le salarié perd 39 euros
de prime d'activité,
il voit ses cotisations
sociales augmenter
de 26% et il rentre
dans l'impôt
sur le revenu.
Autant le dire,
notre système, fruit
de réformes
successives, a placé
notre monde économique
dans une situation
où il n'y a presque
plus aucun intérêt
pour quiconque
à augmenter un salarié
au SMIC.
On ne peut accepter
une France où beaucoup
sont condamnés à rester
proches du SMIC
toute leur carrière.
La progression salariale doit
toujours permettre
de récompenser
l'effort et le mérite.
J'assume de le dire.
Il faut désmicardiser la France.
Dès le prochain projet
de loi de finances,
en nous appuyant
sur les propositions
de partenaires sociaux
et des travaux d'experts
qui sont conduits,
nous commencerons
à réformer ce système.
Nous devons aussi
continuer à baisser
les charges qui pèsent
sur la classe moyenne.
Après la suppression
de la taxe d'imposition,
la taxe d'habitation,
et la baisse
des premières
tranches d'imposition
sur le revenu, il y aura
une nouvelle baisse d'impôts
de 2 milliards d'euros.
La solidarité
nationale va s'exercer
pour nos classes moyennes.
Valoriser le travail,
ce n'est pas seulement
pour les salariés.
Nous agirons aussi
pour nos fonctionnaires
qui permettent
à l'Etat d'avancer
et s'engagent,
en intégrant leurs efforts
à la rémunération.
Un projet de loi sera déposé.
Nous agirons
pour nos indépendants,
tous nos commerçants,
nos artisans,
nos agriculteurs
qui sont indépendants.
En 2026, nous aurons
réformé la catégorie
des indépendants.
Plus de droits,
notamment à la retraite,
c'est l'engagement de la majorité.
Je veux aussi
déverrouiller l'accès
au travail.
Je veux déverrouiller
notre société.
Je vais permettre
à toute personne
qui le peut de travailler
avec en tête
les devoirs de chacun.
Le droit d'être mieux
accompagné
avec la réforme
de France Travail,
mais aussi le devoir
de chercher
un emploi.
Nous avons lancé
une expérimentation
qui conditionne le RSA
à 15h d'activité
pour l'insertion.
Nous généralisons
ce dispositif
à tous les départements
de France d'ici
le 1er janvier 2025.
De plus,
nous devons aller
plus loin dans la réforme
de l'assurance-chômage.
Une négociation a été
lancée en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors,
de la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle
et des parcours.
Nous souhaitons
qu'elle aboutisse
à un résultat ambitieux.
La situation économique évolue.
Nous gardons notre objectif
de plein emploi
et nous devons
inciter toujours
plus à la reprise du travail.
Je serai extrêmement
attentif à l'évolution
de la trajectoire financière
de l'assurance-chômage.
Si cette dernière dévie,
je n'hésiterai pas,
comme la loi le permet,
à demander
aux partenaires sociaux
de remettre l'ouvrage
sur le métier sur la base
d'une nouvelle lettre
aux ambitions très claires.
Il faut inciter
à la reprise d'emploi
sans aucun tabou.
Nous assumerons également
de combattre l'inactivité.
D'un côté, en rendant
les droits effectifs.
Nous avons été
capables de faire
le prélèvement à la source.
Nous arrivons à mettre
en place le chantier
de la solidarité
à la source, pour garantir
la justice sociale,
pour que chacun touche
l'intégralité de ce à quoi
il a le droit.
Combattre les trappes
à inactivité,
c'est permettre
le droit à chacun
grâce à la solidarité à la source.
Je pense notamment
à l'allocation
de solidarité spécifique
qui prolonge l'indemnisation
du chômage et qui permet
sans travailler
de valider des trimestres
de retraite.
Nous avons une cohérence.
On considère
que la retraite doit
être le fruit du travail.
Nous proposerons
la bascule de l'allocation
de solidarité
spécifique au RSA
et la suppression
de cette allocation.
Un système moins coûteux,
c'est un impératif.
Déverrouiller le travail,
c'est aussi répondre
aux attentes de nos concitoyens.
Le rapport au travail a changé.
Je mesure les changements
de mentalité,
les nouvelles attentes
sur les horaires,
la disponibilité
et l'équilibre
entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle.
Ces aspirations
ne doivent pas
être reniées
et caricaturées,
au risque de décevoir
certains ici.
Personne ne demande
un droit à la paresse,
dans notre pays.
Ces aspirations
doivent être regardées
pour ce qu'elles sont.
Notre rapport au travail
est notre rapport
à l'équilibre personnel.
On ne peut pas appliquer les mêmes
calques génération
après génération.
Les attentes changent
et les technologies évoluent.
Comme ministre des Comptes
publics, j'avais décidé
d'expérimenter
dans mon administration
non pas la semaine de,
mais en 4 jours,
sans réduction
du temps de travail.
A certains endroits,
il y a eu peu
de candidats.
A d'autres, ils ont choisi
de pouvoir arriver
plus tôt le matin
et de pouvoir partir
plus tard le soir
pour pouvoir travailler
un jour de moins.
Je demande à l'ensemble
de mes ministres d'expérimenter
cette solution
dans leurs administrations
centrales.
L'Etat doit donner
l'exemple, s'agissant
de l'organisation
de travail, notamment
pour toutes ces personnes
qui travaillent dur
et qui se sentent invisibles.
Je pense notamment
aux personnes
du ménage, parfois
forcées à faire
des heures
de transport en commun
en pleine
nuit
pour ne pas
qu'elles travaillent
avec les salariés.
Je veux que les personnels
d'entretien
de l'administration
qui le souhaitent puissent
travailler
aux mêmes horaires
que tout le monde,
c'est-à-dire
aux horaires de bureau.
Oui, nous devons mieux
prendre en compte
notre rapport au temps.
Nous continuerons
à avancer
dans le chantier du compte épargne
temps universel,
sac à dos social
qui doit permettre
à ceux qui le souhaitent
de travailler...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Il y a un brouhaha continu.
Je vous remercie
de bien vouloir baisser
d'un ton.
Monsieur le Premier ministre?
- Gabriel Attal:
Ils ont compris
que je ne m'arrêterai pas.
Je peux continuer
sans aucune difficulté.
Il faut mieux
prendre en compte
notre rapport au temps.
Nous continuerons
à avancer
dans le chantier du compte épargne
temps universel,
ce véritable sac à dos social
qui doit permettre
à ceux qui le souhaitent
de travailler beaucoup
plus à certains
moments de leur vie,
notamment
quand ils sont jeunes
et qu'ils n'ont pas encore
de responsabilités familiales,
pour pouvoir
ensuite travailler
moins pour développer
un projet
et pour s'occuper
de leur famille
ou d'un proche qui en a besoin.
Il faut déverrouiller
notre économie.
C'est aussi conquérir
de nouvelles libertés,
être capable de continuer
à transformer
et libérer.
Un projet de loi
en ce sens sera examiné
au printemps.
Il permettra notamment
de déverrouiller certaines
professions,
comme les syndics
ou les ventes en ligne
de médicaments
par les pharmacies.
Beaucoup d'entre
vous me l'ont dit:
s'il est un secteur
qu'il faut déverrouiller,
c'est bien le logement.
Le problème du logement est clair.
Il tient à la foi
à l'offre
et à la demande.
Or, pouvoir se loger,
acquérir son logement,
c'est l'assurance d'une
retraite sereine
pour beaucoup de Français.
Nous répondrons
à cette crise du logement
en créant
un choc d'offre
avec cinq solutions
immédiates proposées.
D'abord, nous allons
simplifier massivement
les normes, simplifier l'accès
à MaPrimeRénov',
faciliter la densification,
accélérer
les procédures.
Nous désignerons
ensuite,
dans deux semaines,
20 territoires engagés
pour le logement
où nous accélérons
toutes les procédures,
comme nous avons su
le faire pour les JO pour y créer
30.000 nouveaux logements d'ici
trois ans.
Nous effectuerons
des réquisitions
pour des bâtiments vides,
dont des bureaux.
Nous continuerons à le faire.
Nous continuerons
à soutenir le monde
du logement social.
Nous avons agi
pour lui en maintenant
le taux du livret A.
Nous voulons répondre
aux causes structurelles
de la crise du logement social.
Nous allons contribuer
à faire évoluer
le monde du logement social,
le faire évoluer
pour inciter les élus
à développer
de nouveaux programmes.
Je vous annonce
que nous allons donner
aux maires la main
pour la première attribution
dans les nouveaux logements
sociaux construits
sur leurs communes.
C'était une mesure
attendue
par les élus locaux.
Nous allons aussi
engager un chantier
de réflexion pour faire évoluer
le logement social
pour qu'il réponde davantage
aux classes moyennes.
D'ici 2025,
toutes les communes soumises
à la loi SRU
doivent posséder
au moins un quart
de logements sociaux
sur leur territoire.
Nous proposerons
d'ajouter
pour une part les logements
intermédiaires accessibles
à la classe moyenne
dans ce calcul
des 25%.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
il faut déverrouiller
pour libérer
la croissance.
Je veux aussi
débureaucratiser la France.
Il a été évalué que, chaque année,
60 milliards d'euros
sont perdus à cause
des démarches
et des complexités
de notre quotidien.
Nous engagerons, après l'été,
une nouvelle étape
de la réforme
du droit du travail,
avec un objectif
clair: libérer
nos TPE et nos PME,
simplifier
leur quotidien
et leur permettre
de négocier certaines
règles directement,
entreprise par entreprise.
Cet élan
de simplification
ne doit pas se limiter au travail.
Partout dans notre pays,
les Français
me racontent
combien les normes
les oppressent,
les empêchent de faire
et d'avancer.
Je pense à nos agriculteurs
et je pense
à tous les petits patrons.
Je pense à nos élus
locaux qui croulent
sous les règles et les procédures
administratives.
A date, le nombre
de mots pour dire
des normes
sur LégiFrance s'élève
à plus d'un million.
Nous évaluerons
les normes qui peuvent
être simplifiées
avec les Français
et les professionnels.
Nous regarderons
les démarches qui peuvent
être améliorées.
Mon seul objectif
est de laisser
les Français vivre.
Supprimer des normes,
c'est possible.
10 normes nationales
pour les agriculteurs
vont être supprimées.
Au niveau local,
en Haute-Garonne,
les préfets
et les agriculteurs
se sont accordés
sur la prorogation
de quatre arrêtés préfectoraux.
Cette logique
est étendue à l'ensemble
des départements français.
Simplifier les démarches,
c'est possible.
Je vous annonce
que dès cette année,
chacun pourra enfin
porter plainte
en ligne partout
sur le territoire.
Simplifier pour éviter
la gabegie,
c'est possible.
Je vous annonce une nouvelle règle
générale simple.
Tous les organes,
tous les comités
ou autre
qui ne se sont pas réunis
ces 12 derniers mois
seront supprimés,
par règle générale.
Applaudissements et protestations
Enfin, des pans entiers
de notre économie demandent
des simplifications
drastiques, notamment
pour accélérer le retour
de notre industrie.
Pourquoi?
Trop de délais,
c'est moins de projets
et moins d'emplois,
moins de croissance.
Quand un investisseur
veut implanter
un projet en Europe,
quelque chose
lui saute aux yeux.
En France, il faut
17 mois en moyenne
pour implanter
un projet industriel.
C'est deux fois
moins en Allemagne.
Ce ne peut pas continuer.
Avec le projet de loi
industrie verte,
nous avons marqué
une première étape.
Je vous annonce
que nous déposerons
un deuxième projet de loi
industrie verte.
Il proposera
de demander à la CNDP
de concentrer
ses travaux uniquement
sur les projets
d'envergure nationale.
Ce sera 6 mois de gagnés
pour les autres projets.
La bureaucratie
qui recule,
c'est la liberté qui avance.
Je veux libérer les Français
des contraintes.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
déverrouiller, désmicardiser,
débureaucratiser,
dans un seul objectif:
réarmer notre pays.
Je veux le dire
d'emblée: le préalable
du réarmement
de la France,
c'est la responsabilité
budgétaire.
Nous devons faire preuve d'une
responsabilité exemplaire
dans nos finances publiques.
Il en va de notre
souveraineté
et de la survie
de notre modèle social
ainsi que de la
protection
des plus fragiles.
Il en va de la protection
des classes moyennes,
qui seraient
les premières victimes
des coupes massives et des hausses
drastiques auxquelles
nous serions
contraints
si nous ne tenons pas
notre trajectoire
de réduction
des déficits
et de notre dette.
Pour nous, le meilleur
moyen de réduire
notre déficit
restera le travail
et la croissance.
Pour certains,
la croissance
est un gros mot.
Pour ceux-là, on n'a
que le mot "taxer"
à la bouche.
Vous avez voulu taxer
les heures supplémentaires
des ouvriers,
le patrimoine des retraités
et les successions
des petits agriculteurs.
Quand on taxe tout,
très vite, il n'y
a plus rien à taxer
et on ne taxe
plus rien du tout.
Je vous confirme
que nous poursuivrons
le même cap:
repasser sous les 3%
de déficit public
d'ici 2027
grâce à plus de croissance,
pas
grâce à trop d'impôts,
grâce à des économies
de structures aussi.
Nous mettrons
toute notre force
dans la bataille.
Nous allons renforcer
les revenus
de dépenses.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
ce réarmement
que nous construisons
avec le président
de la République
a un objectif prioritaire:
nous continuerons
à renforcer
notre souveraineté
nationale et européenne,
où nos frontières doivent
être respectées.
La lutte
contre l'immigration
illégale doit continuer
à s'intensifier.
Il faut assumer
d'accueillir
moins pour accueillir mieux.
Nous continuerons
de déployer la border force
qui a permis à des dizaines
d'interpellations
à la frontière italienne.
Je tiendrai l'engagement
de ma prédécesseure
de réformer l'aide
médicale d'Etat.
Nous le ferons avant l'été
par voie réglementaire,
avec une base connue.
Défendre notre souveraineté
nationale,
c'est aussi donner
les moyens nécessaires
à nos armées pour protéger
nos territoires
et nos valeurs.
Nos militaires
se battent au péril
de leur vie
pour défendre notre pays
et notre République.
Dans le cadre de la loi
de programmation militaire,
nous tiendrons nos engagements.
Nous aurons doublé
le budget du ministère
de la Défense
en deux quinquennats.
Avec vous tous,
avec vous toutes,
je veux rendre
hommage aux femmes
et aux hommes de nos armées,
rendre hommage
à ceux qui sont tombés
pour nous défendre.
Leur sacrifice nous oblige.
Notre reconnaissance est infinie.
Applaudissements
Notre souveraineté,
c'est aussi
notre capacité
à répondre aux besoins
de nos concitoyens.
Sur ces fondements,
nous allons réarmer
nos services publics.
Ils ont toujours été une fierté.
Ils doivent le rester.
Pour certains d'entre
eux, ils doivent
le redevenir.
Nous allons réarmer
notre système
de santé.
Je veux rendre hommage
à tous les soignants
de France, chacun
dans leur spécialité.
Ils sont les visages
de l'engagement,
de l'accompagnement,
de l'attention
et de l'humanité.
Applaudissements
Aujourd'hui, quel est le problème?
Malgré le travail
de nos soignants,
le temps médical manque.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Un peu de silence.
- Gabriel Attal:
Nos compatriotes
ne trouvent pas assez de médecins.
Les délais aux urgences
se rallongent.
Cela se traduit
par la désertification
de notre pays
et la saturation
de nos hôpitaux,
en particulier
des urgences.
L'objectif est clair:
plus de temps médical.
Premier pilier:
agir pour qu'il y ait
plus de médecins
devant les Français.
Les effets de la suppression
du numerus clausus
ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement.
Nous devons mettre en oeuvre
des solutions fortes
tout de suite.
Nous procéderons
à la régularisation
des médecins étrangers
sur notre territoire.
C'est pourquoi, aussi,
je vous l'annonce,
je nommerai un émissaire chargé
d'aller chercher
à l'étranger des médecins
qui voudraient pratiquer
en France.
Nous devons faire
revenir les étudiants
qui sont partis
étudier à l'étranger.
Nous devons aussi mieux
reconnaître l'expertise
et la volonté
de soignants,
qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études
et qui ont une véritable
expérience.
Une infirmière
anesthésiste
qui a un bac+5
doit pouvoir,
si elle le souhaite,
rentrer directement
en 3e année de médecine
pour devenir médecin,
si elle le souhaite.
Deuxième pilier:
agir pour qu'il n'y ait
aucun territoire oublié.
Nous avons depuis 2017 déployé
le système d'accès
aux soins.
Dès cet été, chaque département
devra posséder
un tel système.
Je suis prêt à aller
plus loin en restaurant
des obligations de garde
pour les médecins libéraux
en soirée
ou le week-end,
dans leur cabinet,
à l'hôpital
ou en maison de santé.
Troisième pilier:
libérer les médecins
pour qu'ils se concentrent
sur le soin.
Nous poursuivrons
les chantiers engagés,
notamment
pour l'attractivité
de tous les métiers du soin.
Nous allons
accélérer le passage
de 6000 à 10.000
assistants médicaux,
qui permettront
aux médecins de pouvoir
se consacrer davantage
aux patients
et moins aux formalités
administratives.
Cela représente 2,5 millions
de consultations supplémentaires
libérées
pour les patients
tous les ans.
Nous allons poursuivre
notre action
en faveur de l'hôpital.
Les moyens du Ségur
de la santé
ne sont pas encore arrivés
partout.
Ces lenteurs sont insupportables.
Il y a encore aujourd'hui
trop de rendez-vous médicaux
qui ne sont pas honorés.
Pour les médecins,
il est insupportable
d'avoir chaque jour
des patients
qui ont un rendez-vous
et qui ne se présentent pas.
Pour les Français,
il est insupportable
de savoir
que des millions d'heures
sont perdues
alors qu'ils attendent parfois
des mois pour un rendez-vous.
Je souhaite
un principe simple
qui se traduise
par des mesures claires
dès cette année:
quand on a rendez-vous
chez le médecin
et qu'on ne vient
pas sans prévenir, on paye.
Applaudissements
Protéger nos concitoyens,
c'est aussi
les accompagner
à tous les âges
de la vie
et à toutes les étapes
de la vie.
Nous continuerons
à agir pour l'enfance,
notamment l'enfance en danger.
Nous bâtirons une société
où chacun peut vieillir
comme il l'entend,
en facilitant
le maintien
à domicile
de ceux qui le souhaitent
et en améliorant
le quotidien en EHPAD.
Nous avancerons ensemble.
Parler de santé,
c'est trop souvent oublier
la santé mentale.
Le mal-être,
les dépressions,
les pensées suicidaires
ont beaucoup progressé
chez nos jeunes.
Je veux faire
de la santé mentale
de notre jeunesse
une grande cause
de notre action
gouvernementale,
avec, là aussi,
des mesures claires
et immédiates.
D'abord, réformer
le dispositif MonSoutienPsy.
Ce dispositif partait d'une
bonne intention,
mais il n'a pas donné
les résultats escomptés.
Il faut avoir le courage
de le reconnaître,
même
si c'est nous qui l'avons
mis en place.
Je vous annonce donc
que nous allons
le rénover de fond en comble.
Nous allons
augmenter le tarif
de la consultation
remboursée pour limiter
au maximum
le reste à charge
et pour lever tous les verrous.
Nous permettrons
aux jeunes
d'avoir accès directement
aux psychologues pris
en charge sans passer
par un médecin.
De plus, nous allons mailler
notre territoire
de maisons départementales
des adolescents.
Il y en a 50, aujourd'hui.
Je souhaite qu'il y en ait
une par département
dans notre pays.
Pour la santé psychologique,
les infirmières scolaires
sont des relais
essentiels auprès
des élèves.
Elles accomplissent
un travail remarquable.
Elles accompagnent les jeunes
avec disponibilité,
écoute et soin.
Nous devons recruter davantage
d'infirmières scolaires
et mieux reconnaître
leur engagement.
Aussi,
je vous annonce,
et c'est grâce à un amendement
porté
par cette majorité
dans le dernier PLF,
que j'ai décidé de verser
aux infirmières scolaires
en mai prochain
une prime de 800 euros
et de revaloriser leur salaire
de 200 euros net
par mois à compter de cette date.
Je demande également
au gouvernement
de travailler
à des revalorisations
pour les autres
personnels sociaux
et sanitaires en milieu scolaire.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, renforcer
nos pouvoirs publics,
c'est aussi défendre notre école.
Je veux rendre hommage
à nos professeurs
qui s'investissent
tous les jours
au service de notre école,
de nos élèves
et de notre pays.
J'ai souvent dit
ma fierté
d'être leur ministre.
Aujourd'hui,
comme Premier ministre,
je n'oublie
rien
de ce que nous leur devons.
Je serai toujours à leurs côtés.
Je l'ai dit
sur le perron de l'hôtel
de Matignon...
Je l'ai dit
sur le perron de l'hôtel
de Matignon,
dès mes premières minutes
comme Premier
ministre, l'école
est la mère des batailles.
Il faut partir
de la réalité des faits
et pas seulement
des classements internationaux.
Il suffit d'écouter
ce que nous disent
les Français,
notamment les parents
et grands-parents.
Le niveau a baissé
durant ces dernières décennies.
Que nous disent les professeurs?
Que leur métier
est de plus en plus difficile
à exercer.
Ils ont parfois
peur d'enseigner
des pans entiers
de notre histoire
et de notre littérature.
Que nous disent
les jeunes qui envisagent
de devenir enseignants?
La formation
initiale telle
qu'elle est organisée
ne correspond
pas à leurs attentes
et freine
leur vocation.
Nous allons continuer
à leur répondre.
Pour élever le niveau
des élèves, j'avais lancé
le Choc des savoirs.
Il doit se déployer.
C'est assumer
que tout le monde
ne progresse pas au même
rythme,
que tout le monde
n'a pas les mêmes facilités
ou les mêmes difficultés.
La décision du redoublement
sera désormais
à la main de l'équipe pédagogique.
Des groupes de niveaux
se mettront
en place dès cette année
dans les collèges.
Une école du passage
automatique,
où on glisse
de classe en classe
sans vérifier
si on a le niveau
pour passer dans la classe
supérieure,
c'est une école
où tout le monde stagne
et où le niveau baisse.
Nous assumons
de défendre une école
où tout le monde
apprend à son rythme.
Améliorer le savoir,
c'est aussi agir
sur la question des remplacements.
Nous évaluerons
le pacte enseignant.
Veiller au niveau
des élèves,
c'est réagir
aux nouveaux défis
qui les menacent.
Nous avons d'ores
et déjà interdit
le portable au collège.
Nous allons travailler
à mieux réguler l'usage
des écrans dans et en dehors
de l'école
pour nos enfants.
J'ajoute qu'une
école des savoirs,
c'est aussi
une école qui permet
de se projeter dans l'avenir.
Tous les élèves
de seconde devront faire
un stage de deux semaines.
Nous continuerons
à rapprocher l'école
de l'entreprise, des métiers,
des administrations
et des associations.
Une école
qui fonctionne,
c'est une école
où nos professeurs
sont mieux formés.
Nous réformerons
la formation initiale
des enseignants
pour construire
les écoles normales du 21e siècle.
Cette réforme sera
présentée d'ici
au mois de mars.
Une école qui marche,
c'est aussi
une école où les élèves
sont heureux.
Le bien-être des élèves
est resté longtemps
un impensé.
Nous connaissons le résultat.
Ce sont notamment
les drames du harcèlement.
Notre stratégie
contre le harcèlement,
qui a permis de briser
des tabous majeurs,
est concrète.
C'est l'élève harceleur qui doit
quitter l'école,
plus l'élève victime
qui subissait
la double peine.
Je suis fier
que nous ayons décidé
de ce changement.
Nous prendrons en charge
le remboursement
des fauteuils
roulants
de ceux qui en ont besoin,
comme nous nous y sommes engagés.
Nous agirons partout,
et particulièrement
à l'école.
Depuis des années,
l'Etat et les collectivités
se renvoient
la prise en charge
des AESH sur la pause du midi.
Résultat: personne
ne le finance
dans beaucoup d'endroits.
Les élèves
ne sont pas suffisamment
bien accompagnés
au moment du repas
et les AESH
ne peuvent pas faire
un tremplin pour améliorer
leur rémunération.
Je prends une décision claire.
L'Etat prendra
ses responsabilités
et accompagnera
les élèves en situation
de handicap sur le temps
du déjeuner
en lieu et place
des collectivités locales.
C'est un enjeu de solidarité
et de reconnaissance.
Réarmer l'Etat,
c'est réaffirmer
nos valeurs.
La transmission
du savoir est impossible
sans le respect
de l'autorité
et de nos valeurs
républicaines,
au premier rang
desquelles la laïcité.
On ne négocie pas
avec la République,
on l'accepte,
on la respecte,
sans la moindre exception.
Applaudissements
C'est pourquoi nous déploierons
l'expérimentation
de l'uniforme à l'école,
et nous allons généraliser
le port de l'uniforme
si cette expérimentation réussit.
A la moindre entorse
à notre pacte républicain,
il doit
y avoir des décisions
fortes et des sanctions fermes.
Cela doit nous conduire
à réviser l'échelle
des sanctions pour ne rien
laisser passer.
Mesdames et messieurs,
nous devons faire respecter
l'autorité partout,
dans la classe,
dans les familles, dans les rues.
Ce respect s'apprend
à l'école,
mais ce respect
passe aussi
par les familles.
Les violences
de juillet dernier
ont marqué notre pays.
Parmi les émeutiers,
de très jeunes,
parfois, qui semblaient
avoir déjà coupé
les ponts
avec notre société,
qui ne respectaient
plus leurs parents,
pour qui la violence
est un moyen
comme un autre
de tromper leur ennui.
Je ne me résoudrai pas
à ce que l'on préfère
attendre avant de donner
une lourde peine,
alors que c'est très tôt
qu'il aurait fallu agir.
Nous aurons des sanctions
pour les mineurs
de moins de 16 ans.
Pour eux,
on ne peut pas proposer
des peines de travaux
d'intérêt général.
Nous allons créer des travaux
d'intérêt éducatif,
qui seront leur équivalent
et qui seront donnés
plus facilement que des peines
de travaux d'intérêt général.
Cela fera partie
de la révision de l'échelle
des sanctions
dans nos établissements scolaires
que j'évoquais il y a un instant.
Dès le plus jeune âge,
il faut revenir
à un principe clair:
tu casses, tu défies l'autorité,
tu salis, on t'apprend
à respecter l'autorité.
Applaudissements
Nous allons
responsabiliser davantage
les parents.
Dans le cadre
du projet de loi
sur la justice des mineurs,
nous soutiendrons
la mise en place de travaux
d'intérêt général
pour les parents
de jeunes délinquants
qui se sont volontairement
soustraits
à leurs obligations
et responsabilités parentales.
Il est hors de question d'accabler
certaines familles.
Quand on est une mère seule
de plusieurs enfants
dans un quartier,
on peut être dépassé
par les événements
et on n'est pas toujours
responsable de la dérive
de ses enfants.
Pour elles, cette dérive
est une douleur terrible.
Nous devons les aider.
Je ne me résous pas
à ce que nous ayons
une situation
où nous avons des familles
dépassées
par les événements
avec des enfants
qui ne respectent
pas nos règles,
et 50.000 places d'internat
disponibles de l'autre côté.
Nous y répondrons.
Quand un élève sera
sur la mauvaise pente,
plutôt que de le laisser
plonger
dans la délinquance,
nous proposerons
aux parents de le placer
en internat.
Nous allons le couper
de ses mauvaises fréquentations
et lui offrir un cadre,
un enseignement,
une chance.
Le réarmement civique,
c'est le respect
de la loi.
Nos concitoyens
attendent
de nous que nous agissions
encore
et toujours
contre les violences
et contre les trafics,
ainsi que contre les cambriolages.
Ils veulent de l'ordre
dans nos rues.
Comme l'a dit le président
de la République,
nous allons doubler
la présence policière
dans les rues d'ici à 2030.
Nous allons mener
des actions coordonnées
de tous les services
de l'Etat, forces
de l'ordre, éducation,
services sociaux.
C'est le sens des forces
d'action républicaines.
Nous les déploierons
dès la fin du mois
de février.
Contre l'insécurité,
nous nous sommes fixé
deux priorités,
en particulier les cambriolages.
Nous allons
monter d'un cran
dans notre combat
contre la drogue.
Notre stratégie
de harcèlement
contre les dealers
porte ses fruits.
Nous allons taper les dealers
au porte-monnaie
et couper les vivres.
Nous allons geler
les avoirs des trafiquants
de drogue identifiés.
Notre réarmement
civique passe
par une justice
plus rapide
et plus efficace.
Ensemble, nous allons envoyer
un message clair:
l'impunité, c'est fini.
Nous avons décidé
de moyens exceptionnels
pour notre justice.
Ils seront au rendez-vous
pour accélérer
les délais.
Nous allons accélérer
le fonctionnement
de la justice
avec plus de magistrats,
et une organisation
plus respectueuse
de nos concitoyens.
Les Français ne seront
plus convoqués
sur des créneaux
pouvant courir
sur une demi-journée
entière,
mais sur un créneau bien défini.
C'est par ce genre
de mesures
qu'on renoue le lien
entre la justice
et les justiciables.
Notre réarmement civique,
c'est renforcer l'unité
républicaine de notre jeunesse.
C'est le rôle du service
national universel.
Je lance les travaux en vue
de sa généralisation
à la rentrée 2026.
Mesdames et messieurs,
parler
de nos services
publics, c'est parler
de nos territoires.
Chacun n'a pas les mêmes
défis,
les mêmes attentes
et les mêmes besoins.
J'évoquerai demain
la stratégie
sur les territoires.
Je veux ici, car vous êtes élus
de circonscriptions,
et élus locaux
comme moi, vous dire
nos attentes.
Le gouvernement sera
toujours à l'écoute
des territoires
et des élus locaux.
Toutes les solutions
se construiront
avec eux.
Nous cherchons toujours
des solutions adaptées
aux réalités du terrain
en ayant recours
à l'adaptation des normes.
Nous continuerons à avancer.
C'est le sens
de la mission confiée
à Eric Woerth qui nous donnera
ses conclusions
dans les prochains mois.
Nous cherchons un chemin
pour l'autonomie
de la Corse de la République.
Alors que je parle
de différenciation
de territoires,
j'ai une pensée
pour les territoires
d'outre-mer,
où elles s'imposent
tout particulièrement.
Y réarmer nos services
publics est peut-être
encore plus crucial qu'ailleurs.
Les outre-mer
sont un atout déterminant
pour notre pays.
Il y a dans chaque territoire
d'outre-mer l'enthousiasme
de notre jeunesse,
la détermination
à réussir l'avenir.
Nos outre-mer
concentrent aussi
tous les défis
contre la vie chère,
contre l'emploi,
pour la sécurité,
et la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale.
Chacune de nos politiques
publiques doit tenir compte
des spécificités de l'outre-mer.
Face aux enjeux
exceptionnels
de ces territoires,
nous déposerons
une loi sur Mayotte.
Je veux avoir un mot
particulier
pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Je souhaite
que le processus politique
en cours aboutisse.
J'y veillerai.
Vous examinerez
dans quelques semaines
un projet de loi
constitutionnelle
sur l'avenir
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Ensemble, je vous propose
d'accélérer
encore notre transition
écologique.
Le dérèglement
climatique,
ce ne sont pas seulement
quelques degrés
de plus.
Ce sont des vies détruites
par les intempéries,
des exploitations
agricoles menacées,
et toute notre capacité
à nous nourrir,
des maisons
et des immeubles menacés
par la montée
des eaux, fissurés
par les mouvements du sol.
Certains voudraient
une écologie
de la brutalité.
Pour eux, l'écologie
doit être punitive,
douloureuse, doit passer
par la décroissance.
La décroissance,
je le redis,
c'est la fin
de notre modèle social,
et la pauvreté
de masse, jamais
je ne l'accepterai!
Je crois
au contraire
qu'on ne fera pas
l'écologie
contre le peuple.
Je crois au contraire
qu'il faut entendre
les inquiétudes
de tous les Français.
Il faut entendre
les agriculteurs
qui travaillent
et qui s'inquiètent
pour leur avenir et leur métier.
Il faut entendre
les élus locaux
qui veulent développer
leur commune.
Il faut entendre
les millions de Français
des villes moyennes,
des petites communes
et de la ruralité
pour qui la voiture
est gage de travail et de liberté.
L'écologie sans le peuple,
c'est paver
le chemin
aux crises sociales
et au renoncement.
Nous allons bâtir
une écologie populaire,
à la française,
avec les Français,
pour les Français.
C'est le sens
de la planification écologique
et qui protégera
la biodiversité
et permettra
une baisse radicale
de nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre,
une baisse de 55% d'ici à 2030.
Une écologie populaire,
c'est une écologie
où chacun réagit
à la hauteur
de ses moyens.
L'Etat sera exemplaire.
Nous continuerons
d'aider les entreprises
à participer à l'effort.
Je suis fier que les 50
sites industriels
les plus émetteurs,
qui représentaient 10%
de nos gaz à effet
de serre en France,
se soient tous
engagés à réduire
leurs émissions de près
de moitié d'ici
à 2030.
Je vous annonce
que nous lancerons
une initiative similaire
contre la pollution plastique,
pour les 50 sites
qui mettent
le plus d'emballages
plastiques
sur le marché.
Une écologie populaire,
c'est une écologie
des solutions.
Le président de la République
s'était engagé
à lancer une offre
de véhicules électriques
pour 200 euros par mois.
Cet engagement
est tenu et le succès
est déjà au rendez-vous.
Le président de la République
s'est engagé
à développer les RER
métropolitains
et à investir
dans le ferroviaire,
cet engagement, nous le tiendrons.
Une écologie populaire,
c'est une écologie
de la croissance et de l'emploi.
Le retour de l'industrie,
des investissements
en faveur
de la décarbonisation,
les métiers
de la rénovation thermique
ou la circulation
de l'économie circulaire,
la transition
écologique permettront
de faire rimer climat
avec croissance.
Une écologie populaire,
c'est une écologie
qui se construit
au plus près des réalités
des Français et des territoires.
Des concertations
sont en cours partout
en France aux côtés
des élus locaux.
Nous donnerons
à chacun les moyens
de le faire.
Je souhaite
que le financement
de leurs plans locaux
de financement écologique
soit établi partout.
Une écologie populaire,
c'est une écologie
qui protégera notre souveraineté.
Grâce à la sobriété,
aux énergies renouvelables,
au nucléaire.
Nous allons assurer
notre indépendance énergétique.
Je veux le dire sans ambiguïté.
Le nucléaire
est une fierté française.
Le nucléaire,
c'est un atout majeur
pour notre pays!
J'assume d'être à la tête
d'un gouvernement pro-énergie
nucléaire avec une majorité
pro-énergie nucléaire
qui me soutient.
Nous allons continuer
la montée en puissance
de notre parc nucléaire,
investir massivement
dans les programmes.
Cette année, l'EPR
de Flamanville sera prêt.
C'est grâce au nucléaire
que nous pouvons garantir
les meilleurs prix aux Français.
Nous protégerons mieux
les consommateurs
et réglerons les prix
de l'électricité afin
qu'ils se rapprochent
des coûts de production.
Nous développons
les énergies renouvelables
de la même façon
que nous développerons
le nucléaire.
Bâtir une écologie
populaire,
c'est répondre
aux aspirations
de notre jeunesse.
Réussir la transition
écologique
est le défi de notre génération.
Notre jeunesse veut s'engager,
et participer.
Elle se demande
comment être utile
pour la planète.
Nous allons lancer un service
civique écologique
qui rassemblera d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat 50.000 jeunes prêts
à s'engager concrètement
pour le climat.
J'ajoute
que si nous devons réduire
nos émissions et protéger
notre biodiversité,
nous devons aussi nous adapter
au dérèglement climatique.
Nous adapter, c'est nous préparer.
C'est veiller
à ce que chacun,
même les plus fragiles,
soit prêt
à faire face aux ravages
du dérèglement climatique.
Nous présenterons un nouveau
plan d'adaptation
au changement climatique.
Il présentera
des solutions adaptées
à chaque territoire,
notamment les outre-mer.
Je vous annonce
que nous ferons évoluer
le régime de catastrophe
naturelle
pour le moderniser et éviter
que certains assureurs
n'abandonnent
les territoires
les plus à risque.
Enfin, je l'ai déjà évoqué,
nous devons mener
notre réarmement agricole.
Produire et protéger
pour notre souveraineté,
voilà mon approche.
Depuis 2017,
nous avons engagé ce combat
de la souveraineté.
C'est le sens
des différentes lois,
et des 250 millions
d'euros débloqués
pour trouver des initiatives
alternatives.
Nous avons été
précurseurs en Europe
aux phytosanitaires.
Nous avons été
précurseurs en Europe.
Produire, c'est d'abord
donner du temps
aux agriculteurs
pour passer
plus de temps
dans leurs champs
et moins devant leurs écrans.
Je souhaite que la souveraineté
alimentaire
soit inscrite dans la loi.
Il faut aussi protéger face
aux crises climatiques
et sanitaires.
Le gouvernement l'a toujours fait.
Nous avons adopté un budget
de l'assurance récolte
sans précédent
avec un budget historique.
Nous continuerons à le faire.
Protéger face
à la concurrence déloyale,
c'est le combat face
à la réciprocité
et les mesures miroirs
que je vais mener.
Ce combat doit
se mener en Europe
mais nous devons aller plus loin.
Il faut changer de logique.
Tout ne sera pas réglé
en quelques semaines.
Les chantiers sont complexes.
Mais j'assume d'apporter
des réponses rapides partout
où c'est possible.
Sur Egalim,
dès la semaine dernière,
100 inspecteurs ont commencé
leurs inspections.
Dès février, 50%
des remboursements seront versés
aux exploitants,
soit 733 euros
pour une exploitation
utilisant 7 millilitres
de JNR.
Dès la semaine prochaine,
des guichets seront ouverts.
Ils permettront de verser
les premières indemnisations
dès la fin du mois de février.
Le taux de prise en charge
des frais vétérinaires
a été réévalué à 90%.
D'ici le 15 mars,
les aides seront versées
sur les comptes bancaires
des exploitants.
Nous travaillons
avec les régions...
Nous travaillerons
avec les régions
pour que les aides
à l'installation
des jeunes
agriculteurs puissent
être versées
dans les prochaines semaines.
Cela fait plus d'un an
que certains attendent.
La semaine dernière,
le fonds d'urgence Bretagne
a été doublé.
Sur la simplification,
j'ai parlé
du travail au niveau
local, nous allons
le poursuivre.
Nous irons plus loin encore.
Tout ce que nous pouvons
faire dès maintenant,
nous le ferons.
Nous avons avancé.
Dans la discussion
et dans l'échange,
nous avons avancé
avec les agriculteurs
et leurs représentants.
Sur l'élevage,
nous avons mis en oeuvre
un dispositif fiscal
qui doit leur permet
de faire face à l'inflation.
Nous le renforcerons
pour protéger toujours
et davantage nos éleveurs.
J'ai déjà parlé des amendes
et des contrôles.
Toutes les amendes
qui seront infligées
à l'industrie et à la grande
distribution seront redistribuées
pour soutenir financièrement
les agriculteurs.
Sur la viticulture, oui,
nos viticulteurs souffrent,
mais ils font briller la France.
Nous allons débloquer
des moyens nouveaux
avec un fonds d'urgence
pour soutenir
nos viticulteurs,
particulièrement
en Occitanie.
Sur les contrôles,
je lance aujourd'hui
un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité
des produits.
L'objectif est clair:
garantir une concurrence équitable
notamment pour que les normes
appliquées
à nos agriculteurs soient
aussi respectées
par les marchandises étrangères.
Au niveau européen,
trois priorités immédiates.
Les jachères,
les importations ukrainiennes
de volaille et le Mercosur.
Ces sujets sont portés
par le gouvernement
et le président.
Nous nous sommes engagés.
Nous avons une coalition
de 22 pays
sur la question
des jachères
et nous sommes proches
d'aboutir
sur une prolongation
de la dérogation.
Nous ne nous laisserons pas faire.
Nous prendrons
toutes les mesures
pour éviter
toute surtransposition,
d'où qu'elle vienne.
Nous ne sommes pas au bout
du chemin.
Il y aura de nouvelles conquêtes.
Je pense aux jeunes
agriculteurs
et à la transmission
des exploitations.
Nous agissons vite, fort,
avec détermination
et respect pour nos agriculteurs.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs,
réarmer la France,
c'est continuer
à conquérir de nouveaux droits.
Le président
de la République
a fait de l'égalité
entre les femmes
et les hommes sa grande
cause du quinquennat.
Elle sera au coeur
des engagements
de mon gouvernement.
C'est le sens de la réforme
du congé parental,
annoncée par le président
de la République.
Le congé parental
ne laisse pas assez
de revenus aux familles.
Il est souvent
inégalement réparti
dans le couple,
il éloigne durablement
les femmes de l'emploi.
Nous devons combattre
cette inégalité.
Le congé parental
sera transformé
en congé de naissance de six mois,
mieux rémunéré,
les parents pourront
se répartir
entre eux cet argent.
Conquérir
de nouveaux droits,
c'est reconnaître
et défendre le droit
des femmes
à disposer librement
de leur corps.
Nous inscrirons le droit
à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse dans la Constitution.
Conquérir
de nouveaux droits,
c'est être aux côtés
de nos concitoyens jusqu'au bout
de la vie.
La fin de vie est sans doute
des questions
les plus intimes
et délicates qui soient.
C'est se pencher sur son histoire.
C'est repenser
aux souffrances endurées
par certains.
C'est s'interroger sur soi-même.
Sur ce que l'on voudrait face
à l'insupportable
et à l'irréversible.
On ne peut légiférer
sur la fin de vie qu'avec
une grande prudence,
une grande retenue
et un grand respect.
Nos compatriotes
nous appellent à revoir
notre droit.
C'est une demande des familles.
C'est une demande des malades.
C'est un appel grave auquel
nous devons répondre,
nous y répondrons.
Nous renforcerons
considérablement
les unités de soins
palliatifs
dans notre pays.
Il y aura une unité
par département.
Avant l'été,
nous examinerons un projet
de loi sur l'aide
active à mourir
dans notre pays.
Ce débat animera notre société.
Je souhaite
qu'il puisse se tenir
dans une volonté
d'équilibrer
dans le respect
des convictions de chacun.
Madame la présidente,
je viens de tracer
les grandes
orientations que suivra
mon gouvernement.
En suivant ce chemin,
je propose
aux Français
d'avoir pleinement le contrôle
sur leur vie.
Je souhaite que la France
retrouve pleinement
la maîtrise
de son destin,
qu'elle soit pleinement
souveraine.
Une souveraineté
industrielle, technologique
et numérique créatrice
d'innovation
et d'emploi.
Une souveraineté
énergétique,
qui nous protégera des crises,
protégera l'environnement
et garantira des prix plus bas.
Une souveraineté
agricole qui permettra
de nourrir le pays
avec les meilleurs produits,
et d'assurer l'avenir
de notre agriculture.
J'aurai des annonces
supplémentaires
à faire
dans les prochains jours
sur le sujet.
Je parle de souveraineté
nationale.
C'est aussi par l'Europe
que nous parviendrons
à la consolider.
Depuis 2017 et le discours
de la Sorbonne
du président
de la République,
l'Europe a changé.
Elle a surmonté
des crises, pris
ses responsabilités.
C'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons pu
avoir des vaccins
face à l'épidémie.
C'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons bénéficié
du plan de relance massif.
C'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous soutenons l'Ukraine
depuis le premier jour face
à l'agression russe.
C'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons imposé d'énormes
normes aux géants du numérique.
C'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons apposé
un impôt minimal
sur les grandes multinationales
pour lutter
contre l'optimisation fiscale.
Grâce à l'Europe
que nous contrôlerons mieux
nos frontières.
Nous pourrons voir qui rentre
dans l'espace GAN
et qui ne le peut pas.
Les personnes
qui veulent revoir
les traités sont les partisans
d'une sortie
de l'Europe,
ce qui affaiblira la France.
Moins d'Europe,
c'est moins de puissance
pour la France.
Je ne prendrai qu'un exemple.
Le Brexit.
Ses partisans promettaient
des jours heureux
à l'économie britannique
et au peuple anglais.
La semaine dernière,
à cause du Brexit,
les derniers hauts-fourneaux
de Grande-Bretagne
ont fermé.
On ne produit plus d'acier
au Royaume-Uni!
En France, au contraire,
grâce aux investissements
européens, l'industrie revient!
Qui étaient les premiers
partisans
en France du Brexit?
Qui s'est affiché
ouvertement
avec le leader du Brexit?
C'est le Rassemblement National!
L'Europe, éternel
bouc émissaire
de ceux qui, faute
de pouvoir diriger
un pays, veulent détruire
tout un continent.
Pas un Français
ne pense que l'on peut
s'en passer.
Tout n'est pas parfait.
Il reste des chantiers.
Les faits sont là.
Avec l'Europe, notre puissance
est démultipliée.
Nous avons commencé
à la changer
ces dernières années!
Alors que nous sommes presque
à la fin,
les masques doivent tomber.
On ne peut pas vouloir sortir
de l'Europe sauf
à avoir d'autres
intérêts, asservir
un autre pays
ou d'autres puissances!
Applaudissements
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, voilà
les grands principes
qui guideront mon action.
Pour notre France
qui n'a jamais perdu
son ambition de grandeur,
pour ces Français
qui n'ont jamais
manqué à leur devoir.
Ces axes
que je vous ai présentés,
ils sont une réponse
aux enjeux
de la nation.
C'est le reflet
de l'ambition
que nous portons.
Ils correspondent aux rêves
qu'une génération
avait appris à ne plus porter.
Trouver un emploi
stable, fonder
une famille, faire des sacrifices
acceptables s'ils servent
à l'ascension
de leurs enfants,
aimer leurs paysages,
une société libre
et tenue.
Dans une époque
si difficile, il n'y
a pas de réponse
simple
mais il y a des espoirs
tranquilles
à raviver.
J'assumerai toujours
de débattre
avec vous.
Je respecterai
toujours vos opinions,
vos propositions.
Je ne rejetterai
jamais la critique
tant qu'elle est constructive.
J'adresse ces mots
à vous et aux Français.
Je sais leurs attentes.
Les temps sont troublés.
Mais l'espoir est là.
La France est puissante.
Ce qui nous réunit
est toujours
plus fort.
La France, notre pays
et notre nation,
demeurera notre fierté.
Etre français en 2024,
c'est une fierté!
Notre société
est plus ouverte,
plus audacieuse,
plus pionnière
que l'image
que nous nous renvoyons parfois
à nous-mêmes!
Etre français en 2024,
c'est vivre
dans un pays
où l'histoire s'écrit.
C'est vivre
dans un pays
qui n'a pas renoncé
à protéger les droits
de toutes et tous!
Etre français en 2024,
c'est vivre
dans un pays où on se bat
pour la paix!
Etre français,
c'est vivre dans un pays
qui se déchirait
autour du mariage
pour tous,
et être capable 10 ans
plus tard
d'être Premier ministre
en assumant ouvertement
son homosexualité.
Il n'y a aucune raison
de céder
à la fatalité.
Je n'ai qu'une chose à dire
à nos concitoyens.
Quelle que soit leur couleur
de peau,
leur origine,
leurs croyances,
la France est votre pays.
Et en France, tout est possible.
Nous sommes fiers d'être français.
Je veux faire briller
la fierté française.
Le cap pris sous l'autorité
du président
de la République
pour reprendre
notre destin
en main, je viens
de vous le présenter.
Nous sommes prêts.
Nous sommes prêts
à voir la vérité
en face.
Nous sommes prêts
à écouter la voix
de tous les Français,
prêts à agir, prêts
à oeuvrer sans relâche,
fidèles
à notre devise
républicaine, prêts
à garantir la liberté,
prêts à choisir
la fraternité.
Nous ne sommes pas n'importe
quel pays.
Nous ne serons jamais
une puissance moyenne
qui se résignerait
au déclin avec fatalité.
Nous ne sommes pas condamnés
à subir
mais déterminés
à agir et à prendre
notre destin en main.
Nous sommes la France
et rien ne résiste
au peuple français!
L'Assemblée nationale
acclame Gabriel Attal.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le Premier ministre.
...
Merci beaucoup.
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Mattei
pour le groupe MoDem.
...
Merci de quitter
l'hémicycle en silence
pour les personnes
qui nous quittent.
- Jean-Paul Mattei:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier ministre,
mes chers collègues,
j'ai l'honneur
d'être le premier orateur
après votre prise
de parole, monsieur
le Premier ministre.
Votre intervention confirme
ma première impression.
Votre talent,
votre énergie,
est un atout
dans la période
que nous traversons.
Je pense que...
Nous sommes prêts
à passer
tous les caps avec vous,
pas simplement
le cap Horn.
Pour quelqu'un
de ma génération,
la nomination d'un jeune
Premier ministre
a quelque chose
de rassurant pour l'avenir.
Lorsque je me suis engagé,
en 1974,
pendant la campagne
de monsieur Giscard,
vous n'étiez pas né,
avec Marielle
de Sarnez, notamment,
j'ai été saisi
du même sentiment en 2017
avec le président
de la République.
Avec votre arrivée
à Matignon, je ressens
ce même mouvement,
cette même ardeur
et j'ai envie de dire: "chiche"!
Le discours que vous venez
de prononcer s'inscrit
sur ce chemin du dynamisme
qui incarne l'esprit
de 2017.
Les Français avaient choisi
l'optimisme, l'ouverture
et les valeurs démocrates.
Ce sont ces valeurs
que vous représentez.
Je vous sais conscient
de la responsabilité
qui vous incombe,
conscient de la hauteur
de la tâche
qui est la vôtre,
que vous abordez
avec l'audace
et la détermination
nécessaires,
en étant précis et attentif
aux attentes concrètes
des Français.
Le groupe que j'ai l'honneur
de présider
vous fait confiance
pour que vous soyez fidèle
à cette méthode,
fidèle à vos valeurs,
pour mettre en oeuvre
une politique volontariste.
Vous êtes l'un d'entre nous.
Nous avons confiance
en vous et en vos promesses.
Notamment celle de travailler
en étroite collaboration
avec le Parlement
à la transformation
de notre pays.
Notre groupe
vous accompagnera
dès lors que vous
nous proposerez
de travailler
main dans la main
pour des réformes
utiles et justes.
Permettez-moi d'envoyer
un signe d'amitié
et de respect
envers Elisabeth Borne
qui a su conduire
notre majorité
depuis 2022 de façon utile
et constructive.
Je veux ici
la remercier
pour tout ce
qu'elle a donné
à notre pays.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
vous le savez,
vous y avez participé,
beaucoup de réformes
ont été engagées
depuis 2017 pour favoriser
l'économie, l'entreprise
et l'emploi.
Nous avons lancé beaucoup
de grands chantiers.
Il faut reconnaître
que par la force
des crises, les gilets jaunes,
la crise sanitaire,
la guerre en Ukraine,
nous avons beaucoup paré
à l'urgence
sans nous projeter
avec vigueur dans l'avenir.
Force est de constater
que la France
de 2024 n'est
plus la France de 2017.
La guerre est désormais
sur notre sol.
La catastrophe
climatique devient
plus récurrente
et brutale que jamais.
L'accession des pouvoirs
des populistes
a renversé l'ancien équilibre.
Le moment est venu
de rebondir,
d'être à l'offensive
et vous venez
de le prouver.
Nous demandons
des grandes lois
sur le long terme
avec de la programmation,
de la sécurité
juridique, telles
les lois de programmation
de la défense,
de la justice,
de la police,
sur des marqueurs
sociétaux sur lesquels
nous pourrions
retrouver l'adhésion
de nos concitoyens.
Dans cette méthode,
notre groupe
vous accompagnera
avec ce que nous sommes,
déterminés à redonner
de la force
à notre pays, lui rendre
sa souveraineté,
rendre les Français
fiers de constituer
une nation unie et solidaire.
Nous avons de nombreux
défis à surmonter.
Je veux vous apporter
à vous et à Marc Fesneau
notre plein soutien
pour résoudre
la crise agricole actuelle.
Cette crise est multiforme
et le reste
des sujets à traiter aussi.
Comment réindustrialiser
ce pays
pour créer des emplois
et assurer
notre souveraineté?
Comment accueillir
des travailleurs
dans un territoire
lorsqu'on
n'a pas de logement
pour les accueillir
avec leur famille?
Comment répondre à l'exigence
de simplification
sans verser
dans le tout numérique,
la mauvaise calibration
du guichet unique?
Il faut faire
confiance aux tiers
et maintenir le contact.
Comment demander aux Français
le renouvellement
des générations
quand il est impossible
de trouver une pièce
en plus pour loger
les enfants à naître?
L'ascenseur
social et l'école
sont en perte de vitesse.
La culture reste réservée
à certains, seulement.
Comment prendre
en charge nos aînés,
soigner
les Français,
tout ça
quel que soit le territoire
dans lequel ils résident?
Voici nos défis.
Notre devoir est de répondre
à l'ensemble
de ces questions en les menant
de front ensemble,
en tenant compte
des deux éléments fondamentaux:
la crise environnementale
et la crise préoccupante
de nos finances publiques.
Vous avez beaucoup
insisté, monsieur
le Premier ministre,
sur le travail
qui rémunère, qui fait
vivre une famille.
Vous parlez du travail
qui émancipe.
Là-dessus, nous sommes avec vous.
Faciliter les formations
et les embauches
pour les entreprises,
les simplifier
pour qu'elles passent
plus de temps
à chercher de nouveaux marchés
plutôt qu'à faire
de la paperasse...
Nous devons
nous interroger
sur notre fiscalité,
qui n'est
plus adaptée au monde actuel.
Nous ne devons pas briser
les talents.
Vous savez aussi
que notre grande préoccupation
c'est l'immobilier.
De la naissance
au dernier jour,
le logement plutôt
que de représenter
la première
des inégalités doit
être un lieu d'émancipation.
Il faut bâtir une politique
du logement cohérente,
humaine et adaptée
à la société d'aujourd'hui.
Des solutions
existent, même
si elles passent
par quelques bouleversements,
y compris fiscaux.
Certains Etats du monde
ont compris que,
pour réussir,
il fallait gouverner
à 30 ans ou à 40 ans.
En France, nous avons parfois
pris l'habitude
de gouverner à 30 ou à 40 jours.
Cela ne peut plus fonctionner.
Nous voyons
les naissances se tasser
sans réagir.
Nous avons un indicateur
de fécondité
au plus bas depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale,
hormis en 93 et en 94.
Cette question
démographique
ne doit pas être prise
à la légère.
Elle est cruciale
pour l'avenir
de notre nation.
Notre contrat social,
qui fait la richesse
de la France, repose
sur cet indicateur.
Il Agir pour la progression
démographique suppose d'abord
de combattre avec une totale
détermination
les inégalités.
Il faut une politique
familiale
et une protection
de l'enfance ambitieuse,
comme ce que
nous avons bâti
depuis six ans.
La création d'une
délégation aux droits
de l'enfance en est une belle
illustration.
L'éducation est le coeur même
de l'émancipation
de tous les élèves.
Tous les élèves
doivent se prévaloir
des mêmes chances
dans toutes les écoles.
Nous savons tous
ici que la réussite
du système
éducatif dépend
surtout du bien-être
de l'accompagnement
et du nombre de professeurs.
Encourageons
les vocations, aidons
les professeurs
à s'installer
dans tous les territoires.
Il y a un autre défi
qui nous attend:
celui du vieillissement
massif
de la population,
qui entraîne des défis immenses.
Explosion des demandes
de protection sociale,
nouvelles exigences
des services publics
en termes d'assistance
et de soins...
Je souhaiterais aussi
aborder les défis
des territoires.
Je parle de tous les territoires.
Je parle des territoires
de l'Hexagone
et des territoires
d'outre-mer qui méritent
une attention forte
du gouvernement.
Maintenir notre modèle
économique
et social suppose de mener
une politique volontariste
de réduction des inégalités
territoriales.
Soutenons les médecins
volontaires.
L'ouverture du numerus
clausus est actée.
L'exigence d'égalité
territoriale,
c'est aussi l'accès
aux services publics
avec une administration
qui aide, plutôt
que de traquer et punir.
C'est enfin en soutien
à nos agriculteurs.
Comment accepter qu'après
les lois Egalim,
nous en soyons au même constat?
Nos agriculteurs
qui nourrissent
par leur force de travail
les Français n'arrivent
toujours pas à vivre
décemment
de leur activité.
Ils restent coincés
dans le fossé
que la grande distribution
a largement creusé
entre le consommateur
et le producteur.
Vous venez de faire
de fortes propositions
qui viendront s'ajouter
aux grands textes
à venir sur le renouvellement
des générations.
Je souhaite
qu'elles soient de nature
à répondre au malaise
agricole profond.
Voici
ce que nous croyons
et ce que nous espérons
pouvoir faire
avec vous dans un contexte
de grand bouleversement.
Le plus grand bouleversement,
nous l'avons
tous en tête:
le dérèglement climatique.
Avec la question
du pouvoir d'achat,
il est de plus en
plus difficile
de faire accepter
à nos concitoyens
des changements dans leur mode
de consommation,
alors que la nécessité
d'agir se renforce.
Il faut agir vite
et fort pour réduire
nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
La question
la plus délicate
est de savoir qui finance
la transition énergétique
et comment on fait
pour que les Français
ne subissent pas cette transition.
C'est un enjeu important.
Vous allez devoir vous y atteler.
Nous sommes tous
convaincus que l'urgence
est là.
Nous ne devons pas assister
impuissants
à la dégradation du vivant.
Notre partenaire
le plus important
sur ce sujet,
comme sur l'agriculture,
la défense, la solidarité
et la santé sera
une nouvelle fois
l'Union Européenne.
2024 sera l'année européenne.
J'ai confiance dans tous
les démocrates
pour mettre
toutes leurs forces
dans la campagne
des valeurs européennes.
C'est encore plus important
face
au grand bouleversement
à l'échelle internationale,
dont nous n'avons pas encore
véritablement pris
la pleine mesure.
Ce sont les conséquences
de la situation
au Moyen-Orient
et les souffrances
du peuple ukrainien,
ou encore les incertitudes liées
aux élections américaines.
Ce qui se joue
est donc de renforcer
et de consolider
l'Union Européenne.
Défendre nos valeurs
européennes
et démocrates,
cela implique aussi
de changer de méthode
dans notre hémicycle.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
je le disais au début
de mon propos,
votre nomination
nous rappelle l'esprit
de 2017.
Renouer avec 2017,
c'est aussi renouer
avec le dépassement
des clivages,
des antagonismes,
des postures, dépassement
de nos vieilles habitudes.
Le groupe démocrate défend
depuis longtemps l'importance
de moins légiférer
pour mieux légiférer
en travaillant
sur moins de textes,
mais des textes plus structurants.
Mieux évaluer
aussi l'efficacité
des politiques publiques.
Je sais que nos difficultés
sont aussi liées
à notre mode de scrutin,
premier germe
de la division.
Ainsi, nous devons
nous poser
cette question.
Tout cela implique
de faire des efforts
et de respecter
nos différences plutôt
que de les cultiver.
Ce sont les qualités
qui prévalent
au groupe démocrate,
qui s'est construit
sur l'unité, la positivité,
le rassemblement
des valeurs.
Nous avons une vision
sociale, démocrate
et humaniste.
Nous serons à vos côtés
pour la faire vivre.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le président.
Applaudissements
Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Boris Vallaud
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Boris Vallaud:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
nous connaissons votre bilan.
C'est celui du président
de la République.
La crise du logement,
la crise de l'hôpital,
la crise de l'école,
la crise des salaires,
la crise des finances publiques...
C'est la réforme
de l'assurance chômage,
la réforme du RSA,
la réforme des retraites...
C'est aussi ce moment coupable
de bascule morale,
avec la loi immigration.
Nous connaissons votre projet.
C'est celui du président
de la République,
libéral et conservateur,
la cohabitation assumée
avec la droite
dont vous conduisez désormais
la politique.
Nous pourrions parler
longtemps de vous.
Je voudrais parler des Français.
Notre rôle est de transformer
la critique
en action.
Le pays souffre.
Le mal qui le ronge
est l'injustice.
Vous préparez déjà
une nouvelle réforme
du marché du travail
et de l'assurance chômage faite
de mauvais coups.
Vous prétendez défendre
la valeur travail.
Nous défendons
pour notre part la valeur
du travail.
Nous voulons
que la valeur change
de camp
et qu'elle ne soit plus du côté
des rentiers,
des actionnaires
et des rémunérations
extravagantes,
mais du côté du travail
et des travailleurs.
Nous défendons la France
des ronds-points
et des sous-préfectures.
Vous défendez la France
du rond-point
des Champs-Elysées.
Nous voulons
que le travail paye
et qu'il paye bien,
pas de cette France
de travailleurs pauvres.
Nous défendons la taxation
des multinationales
et des superprofits, pas vous.
Nous défendons
une limitation des écarts
de rémunération de 1
à 20, pas vous.
Nous voulons que la valeur
soit du côté
de l'utilité sociale.
L'heure est venue d'une radicale
reconsidération morale
et économique des métiers du soin.
Nous avons besoin
plus que jamais
des infirmières,
des aides à domicile,
des assistants d'éducation,
des aides-soignantes.
Nous voulons bâtir
un modèle économique
pour le 21e siècle
où le travail
est mis au service
de la pleine santé.
Vous parlez d'emploi,
nous voulons parler
de travail.
Nous voulons parler
de santé au travail,
du temps de travail libéré,
de l'organisation
du travail et des processus
de production.
Le temps de travail
et le travail
comme mise en commun.
Nous défendons
le dialogue social,
le dialogue professionnel
et la codétermination
dans l'entreprise.
Ce dont il faut
se débarrasser,
ce n'est pas du travail.
Les gens aiment leur métier.
Il faut se débarrasser
des rapports
de domination.
Vous voulez libéraliser
le travail.
Nous voulons toujours
mieux le civiliser.
Nous défendons le travail
qui émancipe, porteur
de sens.
Vivre dignement,
c'est aussi compter
sur le service public,
si durement attaqué
par vos réformes.
Quand les aides
sociales reculent,
les inégalités avancent
et les injustices prospèrent.
Les Français
les plus modestes,
sans interlocuteur,
aux prises
avec des services
sociaux chamboulés
par l'austérité,
fragilisés
par vos réformes
suspicieuses,
en sont les premières victimes.
Ce qui caractérise
le présent,
c'est l'incertitude
qui laisse
les plus fragiles
sur le bord du chemin.
Ce que nous devons
imaginer,
ce sont les services
publics de demain.
C'est une protection
sociale qui apprivoise
le hasard.
L'Etat social
de demain est celui
du retour
à l'universel
qui n'oublie pas les classes
moyennes qui,
trop souvent, ont le sentiment
de n'avoir droit
à rien.
C'est celui des droits
et des mécanismes
de solidarité.
Ce sont des droits
pour tous plutôt
que des allocations pour certains.
C'est l'extension
des services publics
et leur gratuité,
comme dans les transports publics.
C'est l'assurance
maladie obligatoire
à 100% pour tous,
c'est le minimum vieillesse
et les repas à 1 euro.
Ce qui doit
être laissé ou retiré
au marché, comme les EHPAD
ou les crèches...
Je voudrais insister
sur la mixité sociale
à l'école.
La cohésion
nationale est minée
par la ségrégation,
aboutissant
au repli social.
Je le dis aux obsédés
du réarmement civique
et de la régénération,
aux inquiets
de la décivilisation:
la République sociale
est la meilleure
façon de prendre
en charge le sentiment national.
C'est la seule voie
pour surmonter
le dilemme que nous combattons.
Jamais la crise
n'aura paru
ni plus tangible,
ni plus violente,
ni porté aussi nettement
son cortège d'injustices
et d'inégalités.
Alors que nos paysans
souffrent, chacun
le sent,
l'agriculture
ne traverse pas une simple crise.
Elle est au coeur
d'une révolution
à la confluence de la critique
du libéralisme.
Elle est au coeur
de la contestation
et de l'impératif écologique.
Ce qui sombre est une organisation
socioindustrielle basée
sur l'agrandissement
des structures
et sur la spécialisation
ainsi que sur
un libre-échange destructeur.
Il faut une refondation
de la PAC
à Bruxelles et une vraie
loi d'orientation.
Nous n'avons ni l'un ni l'autre.
Un cap: l'agroécologie
et le renouvellement
des générations.
Un impératif: le juste partage
des valeurs face
à la grande distribution
et aux industries
agroalimentaires.
Une condition:
la protection
de nos marchés face
à une mondialisation déloyale.
Il n'est plus possible
de faire semblant.
Nous avons besoin
d'un grand plan
de bifurcation écologique.
Nous voulons un plan
de décarbonation
de notre industrie.
Nous devons défendre
nos intérêts souverains
et préparer l'avenir
en construisant
la machine
de l'industrie de demain
avec les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui.
Notre écologie,
c'est l'écologie
des vulnérables,
une écologie à hauteur d'homme,
de la vie quotidienne,
qui desserre
la ceinture des plus faibles.
Nous voulons
plus de justice
et moins de carbone.
Partout dans le monde,
la dénonciation
de l'injustice,
l'urgence écologique
et le combat démocratique
sont intimement liés.
Depuis septembre,
l'exécutif méprise
le dialogue social
et brutalise le Parlement.
Le président de la République
aura fini d'épuiser
la Ve République et d'animer
la politique lorsque
les citoyens
lui conservent du crédit.
Il a oublié les conditions
de son élection face
à l'extrême droite.
Toute concession
est une faute morale.
Toute tentative
de régulation
est une erreur tactique.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, il n'y
a qu'un pas de la faiblesse
à la trahison.
Ce pas, vous l'avez franchi.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
après 7 ans de macronisme,
les socialistes
sont épuisés.
L'idéal républicain d'émancipation
n'a jamais été aussi lointain.
Quand les incertitudes
sont fortes
et que l'avenir
apparaît sans issue,
l'entre-soi devient un refuge.
Chacun défend
sa colère et sa vision
du monde.
Il existe un autre
chemin, notre idéal.
Tout n'est pas
à refaire
et tout est entre nos mains.
Nous voulons abattre
les barrières
qui s'opposent
à la fraternité humaine.
On me dira
que la fraternité
n'est pas un projet politique.
C'est le seul
qui vaille pour sortir
les hommes et les femmes
de la solitude
dans laquelle les laisse
votre politique.
Votre oeuvre abandonne
les plus faibles
à leur destin de perdants.
Je vous ai écouté.
Vous êtes le jeune
visage du vieux monde.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Laurent Marcangeli
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Laurent Marcangeli:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier
ministre, mesdames
et messieurs les ministres,
mes chers collègues,
je m'adressais
à vous il y a un an
et demi au début
de votre mandat
en soulignant
la difficulté de la tâche
qui vous attendait.
Je vous faisais part
d'une conviction,
celle selon laquelle
nous vivons
un instant
décisif de la vie
de notre pays.
Force est de constater
que je peux reprendre
ces termes pour décrire
la situation actuelle.
Crise inflationniste,
crise agricole,
crise géopolitique,
crise démocratique...
Nous sommes toujours
à cette croisée
des chemins.
Nous assistons
jour après jour
à la complexification
du monde
qui nous entoure,
les défis à relever
sont donc toujours aussi nombreux.
Néanmoins, et en dépit d'une
situation politique inédite,
nous avons fait adopter
plus de 50 textes,
tous nécessaires,
depuis l'élection
de cette Assemblée.
Nous avons su trouver
des consensus
quand c'était possible
et des compromis
quand ça ne l'était pas.
Les années qui viennent
nous seront utiles uniquement
si nous fixons un cap clair.
Ce cap, c'est celui
d'une France
plus juste
et plus prospère
pour le plus grand nombre.
Je salue l'action
d'Edouard Philippe,
Jean Castex et Elisabeth Borne.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, les espoirs
et attentes
de nos concitoyens
sont immenses.
La tâche
pour ne pas les décevoir
est d'autant plus ardue.
Comme avec votre
prédécesseur,
vous trouverez les députés
du groupe Horizons
et apparenté à vos côtés
pour travailler
dans le sens de l'intérêt général.
Partenaire sérieux,
partenaire loyal,
mais partenaire
exigeant,
c'est ainsi que
nous concevons
votre action gouvernementale.
Nous devrons apporter
des réponses rapides,
mais pérennes, sur plusieurs
sujets prioritaires,
que je me permettrai
de décliner
dans la suite de mes propos.
Surtout, ces solutions
ne porteront
leurs fruits
que si elles sont de bon sens.
Nous croyons fermement
que l'immense majorité
des Français
souhaitent en réalité
de la justice,
de la simplicité
et de l'efficacité.
Depuis quelques jours,
les revendications agricoles
nous rappellent à quel point
de nombreux Français
se sentent abandonnés
dans l'époque
qui est la nôtre.
Ils y sont parfois prisonniers.
Ils désespèrent
de la qualité
de nos débats
publics
et ne manquent pas
de nous le faire savoir.
Je demande à chacune
et à chacun
de sortir de ses certitudes
en regardant
la France
telle
qu'elle est et non pas telle
qu'on voudrait
qu'elle soit.
Les récents mouvements
nous démontrent
que la surtransposition
de normes
est une bombe
à retardement
pour les secteurs
qui la subissent.
Il nous faut
à tout prix éviter
que l'agriculture
française connaisse
un déclin similaire à celui
de la sidérurgie
au siècle dernier.
Nous saluons
les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement.
Elles vont dans la bonne
direction.
Je dis
cela sans renier rien
de notre engagement pro-européen.
Nous voulons une Europe
qui s'affirme davantage
sur la scène mondiale,
une Europe
au service de ses citoyens
et une Europe
qui ne crée pas de contraintes
excessives
ou de concurrence déloyale.
La question de la juste
rémunération
de nos agriculteurs
pourrait se poser
dans d'autres domaines.
Le travail doit payer,
c'est une question
de bon sens.
C'est l'un des fondements
de notre contrat social.
Je pense à ceux qui cumulent
les heures
de travail et parfois
les emplois
et qui n'arrivent pas
à boucler
les fins de mois.
Ce sont les mêmes
qui ressentent souvent
une contrainte fiscale accrue.
La société
du travail doit
être notre boussole.
Travailler dur
doit permettre
à nos concitoyens
d'augmenter, d'améliorer
leur niveau de vie.
De telles situations génèrent
un sentiment d'absence
de considération auquel
nous devons remédier,
notamment
en faisant en sorte
qu'il soit toujours
préférable de travailler.
Cette considération
doit être la même
à Paris qu'à Carbonne.
La mobilité,
c'est de pouvoir changer
de lieu d'habitation
et de ne pas subir
une forme d'assignation
à résidence.
Or, la crise
du logement est là
et elle n'épargne personne.
Elle concerne d'abord
l'accès à la propriété
avec des acheteurs
potentiels qui font face
à une hausse
des taux d'intérêt
et à une baisse
des crédits accordés
par les banques.
Initialement créé
pour répondre
à ce besoin, le logement
social ne tient
plus sa promesse républicaine.
C'est donc
une double peine
pour la majorité
de nos concitoyens
qui sont exclus
des logements sociaux
tout en étant
confrontés à des prix
sur le marché
libre bien au-delà
de leurs capacités.
La crise du logement
nous oblige
à une réponse
rapide, globale
et de long terme.
Faire preuve de bon sens,
c'est aussi investir
pour notre avenir,
pour notre jeunesse,
en poursuivant
nos efforts au service
de l'éducation.
Les professeurs sont aujourd'hui
mieux rémunérés.
Nous sommes entrés
dans une nouvelle ère face
au harcèlement
scolaire, celle
de la tolérance zéro.
Beaucoup reste à faire,
en particulier
sur le respect
de l'autorité
de cette institution qu'est
le corps enseignant.
Je sais votre attachement
à ce ministère
qui fut le vôtre.
Là encore,
vous pourrez compter
sur nous.
Cette capacité
à voir loin
pour nos enfants
se traduit par la prise
en compte de l'urgence
écologique
dans l'enseignement
de politiques publiques.
Le cycle des événements
climatiques extrêmes trouble
la quiétude de nos habitants.
Nous prônons une écologie
pragmatique fondée
sur le réalisme
et toujours de bon sens.
Les prochains textes
que nous serons amenés
à voter devront
prendre cette réalité
en compte et permettre
à la France
de tenir son objectif
de neutralité carbone
à horizon 2050.
Au-delà de la protection
de la planète,
je veux rappeler
notre engagement
pour la protection des Français
en matière militaire,
de justice et de sécurité.
Trois lois de programmation
historiques
ont été votées
par le Parlement
en un an.
Elles dotent notre pays d'une
trajectoire claire
sur le fichage
des dépenses
dans des champs
régaliens stratégiques
sur plusieurs années.
Nous continuerons
notre politique fiscale.
La feuille
de paie
ne doit pas être l'ennemi
de l'emploi, quitte
à paraphraser Jacques Chirac.
La réforme de notre système
de santé doit
se poursuivre.
Personne,
sur ces bancs, ne peut
se satisfaire qu'une
grande partie
de nos concitoyens
soit privée d'une offre
de soins accessibles
dans un délai raisonnable.
Le groupe Horizons
l'a déjà affirmé.
C'est aux acteurs
locaux d'organiser
les soins en fonction
des besoins
de chaque territoire.
Si la baisse de la natalité
nous inquiète,
il faut se préoccuper
du vieillissement
de notre population.
La proportion
des plus de 50 ans
est amenée à doubler d'ici 50 ans.
Je fais partie
de ceux qui pensent
qu'il ne faut modifier
la Constitution qu'avec
une main tremblante.
Certains changements apparaissent
pourtant nécessaires,
compte tenu
de l'évolution
de notre société.
Le statut d'autonomie
de la Corse
a été évoqué
lors de votre discours,
par exemple.
Vous l'aurez compris,
le groupe Horizons souhaite
que notre pays
retrouve du bon sens.
Notre programme
de travail est chargé,
pour peu de temps utile.
Notre programme est clair.
Soyons efficaces.
Parlons de fond.
Trouvons le consensus.
Faisons disparaître
ce sentiment
de mépris.
Vous pouvez compter sur nous.
Votre groupe loyal
et exigeant sera
à vos côtés pour faire
réussir la France.
La parole est à la présidente
du groupe écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
vous venez de proclamer
votre de politique générale.
Vous avez posé
les priorités
de votre gouvernement,
avec l'emphase
qui vous caractérise.
Vous donnez l'impression
du mouvement
alors que tout reste figé.
"De l'action, de l'action,
de l'action".
Vous ceinturez
l'espace médiatique
avec de petites
et grandes annonces,
en espérant
que cela nous fasse oublier
que la France
s'appauvrit
et que le climat se détériore.
Votre rôle est celui
d'un écran de fumée.
Après 7 ans au pouvoir,
à agir au sein
de la majorité
et dans les gouvernements
successifs d'Emmanuel
Macron, permettez-moi
de vous juger non
sur votre parole
mais sur votre politique.
Commençons par votre bilan face
au péril climatique.
Le climat s'emballe.
Si rien ne change,
la terre se réchauffera
de 3 degrés d'ici 2100.
Les Etats se contraignent
dans un statu quo
qui nous mène à la catastrophe.
La France ne fait pas exception.
Le 10 mai 2023,
le Conseil d'Etat exhortait
votre gouvernement
de faire baisser
les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2030,
comme inscrit dans la loi.
Vous avez supprimé les nouveaux
objectifs climat
en réponse.
L'agence internationale
de l'énergie appelle
à renoncer à tout nouveau
projet pétrolier
ou gazier dans le monde.
Vous avez autorisé 8 nouveaux
forages pétroliers
en Gironde.
Le Nord-Pas-de-Calais subit
des inondations,
La Réunion,
un cyclone, et vous,
vous soutenez des projets
routiers anachroniques
comme l'A69.
Vous consacrez 0,74%
du budget de l'Etat
à la biodiversité.
La ressource en eau
pourrait diminuer
de 40% d'ici à 2050,
et vous, vous réduisez
les objectifs de révision
de prélèvement
de l'eau par l'industrie.
Les conditions vitales
de l'existence
ne se négocient pas.
Les écologistes
sont aux côtés
de celles
et ceux qui luttent
pour notre survie,
qui démantèlent
les projets climatisés
et désarment
les multinationales.
Nous allons
continuer à défendre
des politiques
environnementales judicieuses.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
votre politique
est finalement
très cohérente.
Vous défendez
ceux qui s'accaparent
la Terre
comme vous encouragez
ceux qui s'accaparent
les richesses.
Bien souvent, ce sont les mêmes.
Voici les conséquences
concrètes
de votre politique.
1 enfant sur 5 vit
dans la pauvreté.
1 Français sur 4
ne mange pas sa faim.
2 Français sur 10
n'arrivent pas à payer
leurs factures à temps.
Vu vos annonces,
ils seront encore nombreux
à se serrer davantage
la ceinture:
pas de vacances,
pas de plus si plaisir,
seulement travailler
pour les factures.
Vous avez capitulé
face aux inégalités.
Vous n'avez jamais cherché
à les combattre.
Vous êtes arrivé
au pouvoir
en étant persuadé que la France
souffrait davantage d'inégalités
de destin que d'inégalités
de revenus.
Combattre les inégalités
de destin,
c'est donner
à chacun les moyens
de s'émanciper,
de s'épanouir
grâce à l'éducation,
la culture
et le sport, c'est combattre
le séparatisme
des riches, c'est donner
à l'enseignement public
les moyens de mener
à bien sa mission,
offrir à tous les enfants
de France l'opportunité
d'apprendre et de grandir,
tout simplement.
Qui peut croire
qu'on peut combattre
les inégalités de destin
en laissant croître
les inégalités de revenus?
Les opportunités
ne sont pas les mêmes
pour les 10% de Français
les plus pauvres
qui disposent
pour tout patrimoine
de quelques milliers
d'euros
sur un livret
A et pour les 10% de Français
les plus riches
qui détiennent,
en moyenne, un patrimoine de 1,1
million d'euros.
Disposer
d'un patrimoine élevé,
c'est le droit
à l'erreur, de prendre
son temps, le temps
de se construire
et de se découvrir.
Nous proposons
l'évidence:
non pas de tout taxer,
mais de reprendre
aux profiteurs,
de remettre les superprofits
au pot commun et d'instaurer
un ISF climatique.
Il est de votre responsabilité
de garantir
la juste répartition
des richesses.
Il faut mener
une bataille féroce
contre les adversaires
que sont l'accaparement
et le superprofit.
Force
est de constater
que vous avez volontairement
capitulé.
Vous parlez d'autorité,
de sanctions
contre les jeunes,
les chômeurs,
les précaires...
Globalement, les Français.
Mais vous manquez
de courage
quand il faut
s'en prendre aux cupides,
aux multinationales
dont les marges
ont bondi
pendant la crise
car elles spéculent
sur la guerre
et les catastrophes climatiques.
Les actionnaires considèrent
les énergies fossiles mortifères
comme une machine à cash.
Un an que les agriculteurs
se démènent,
et la fortune des trois frères
qui possède Lactalis représente
des milliards.
Pendant que les nappes
phréatiques
se vident,
les actionnaires de Nestlé
se sont partagé 19 milliards.
Pendant que les prix d'achat
aux agriculteurs
ont baissé de 9%,
les seuls gagnants,
ce sont les industries
agroalimentaires
dont les marges
sont passées de 28%
à 48% en un an.
C'est pour cela
que les écologistes
sont naturellement
solidaires du mouvement
des agriculteurs.
Depuis 30 ans,
les écologistes se battent
contre les accords
de libre-échange
qui les soumettent
à de la concurrence déloyale.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
votre seule réponse est de réduire
les protections
environnementales,
les normes
qui protègent la santé
des paysans et des terres
qu'ils cultivent.
Ces réponses sont inadaptées.
Elles n'affrontent pas
l'agrobusiness.
La crise ne sera pas enrayée.
Le déclin de l'agriculture
française
va continuer.
Depuis 7 ans,
vous avez activement,
volontairement,
sciemment capitulé face
aux profiteurs des crises.
Mettons les mots
sur votre politique,
posons les mots
et parlons d'égoïsme
pour un gouvernement
qui enrichit
une minorité
au détriment du reste
de la nation.
Parlons d'impunité
quand le président décide
d'utiliser son statut,
l'autorité
de l'institution
qu'il représente,
la visibilité
dont il bénéficie
pour écraser la parole des femmes
victimes d'hommes considérés
comme intouchables.
Parlons de déchéance morale
après l'adoption
de la loi immigration
qui reprend
les obsessions et les mensonges
de l'extrême droite,
alors que ces milices
défilent
dans nos rues, à Lyon,
Annecy ou à Romans-sur-Isère.
Parlons
d'incompétence
quand vous êtes incapable
de nommer
un ministre du Logement
depuis un mois
et que vous allez
encore fragiliser
le logement social
et que vous annoncez
tout au plus 30.000
logements
alors qu'il en faut 500.000.
Le 9 janvier dernier,
vous adressiez
à votre opposition
en ces termes:
"Nous avons en commun
le destin
de notre nation."
Les décisions que nous prenons ici
et maintenant
façonneront en effet
notre destin
commun et celui
de nos enfants.
Soyez assuré
que votre opposition
de gauche et les écologistes
défendent ensemble
une politique
de progrès social
et de justice climatique.
Ensemble,
nous avons voté la hausse
du SMIC, la prime alimentaire,
l'interdiction
de substances cancérigènes,
des jets privés:
vous y êtes systématiquement
opposé.
C'est un changement
radical
dont nous avons besoin.
Vos capitulations
successives ont amoindri
la France.
La France doit
reprendre son souffle.
Elle doit aussi
reprendre sa place
dans le concert des nations.
La France est une boussole
au niveau international.
Sa place a été abîmée
par la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron.
La cour internationale
de justice alerte
sur le risque de génocide à Gaza.
La place de la France
doit être du côté
du droit, de la raison,
de la paix
et de la vie.
La France doit
activement oeuvrer
pour le retour des otages,
et doit exiger fermement
un cessez-le-feu
immédiat et permanent.
Victor Hugo
définissait la France
de 1789 comme "une grande
Lumière mise
au service d'une grande Justice".
Nous nous battrons
sans relâche
pour que la France
redevienne la nation
qui lutte
contre les inégalités,
pour que la France
se dresse enfin
contre l'accaparement
des terres
et de l'eau.
Nous continuerons
à nous battre
pour une certaine
idée de la France,
la France qui ose,
qui n'a pas peur,
qui s'entraide,
malgré vous et vos annonces
rétrogrades.
Nous continuerons à faire
vivre la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
La parole est à présent
à monsieur
le président André Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne:
Madame la présidente,
chers collègues,
monsieur le Premier ministre.
Lors de sa réélection
en avril 2022 face
au Rassemblement National,
le président Macron
avait déclaré
que "ce vote l'obligeait
pour les années à venir".
Cet engagement n'a
trouvé d'échos
ni dans la politique
menée
ni dans la pratique du pouvoir.
Les élections législatives
avaient pourtant confirmé
la nécessité pour le camp
présidentiel, privé
de majorité absolue,
de gouverner autrement
et de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs.
Le mandat de madame Borne s'est
au contraire inscrit
dans la continuité
de pratiques brutales avec,
pour pratiques nouvelles, 23 49.3.
S'il fallait
attribuer une palme,
elle serait décernée
à celui qui s'est abattu
sur la réforme
des retraites
malgré l'opposition
de 80% des Français
et de la majorité de l'hémicycle.
Violence institutionnelle
et reniement
des engagements:
tel est le résumé
de ce début de quinquennat
qui s'est achevé
en donnant à l'extrême droite
une victoire idéologique majeure
en cédant aux fantasmes,
avec l'adoption
d'un texte
sur l'immigration contraire
à nos lois fondamentales,
en créant
un appel au racisme,
tout en fragilisant
notre Etat de droit.
De nombreuses mesures
ont certes été censurées
par le Conseil
constitutionnel,
mais l'irréparable a été
commis, laissant
derrière son passage blessures
et conséquences.
Vous êtes non
seulement responsable
de ce triste bilan,
mais vous avez été désigné
comme commissaire politique
par le président
de la République pour poursuivre
l'oeuvre entamée
le 16 janvier dernier.
Il vous a rappelé
que le détenteur suprême
du pouvoir exécutif, c'est lui.
Vous venez
de le confirmer
avec votre gouvernement
mondain
et de l'entre-soi.
Vous servirez
sa politique au service
des riches, une politique
qui creuse toujours davantage
les inégalités,
sans jamais douter,
avec arrogance.
C'est cette feuille
de route
qui vous a été confiée.
La vacance
tant de ministères
de votre gouvernement
atteste
de la quintessence
idéologique
de ce projet politique.
L'hôpital public se meurt,
laissant 6,7 millions
de personnes
sans médecin traitant.
Ce gouvernement
n'a pas de ministère
de la Santé de plein exercice!
Alors que le nombre
de travailleurs pauvres
et précaires explose,
ce gouvernement
ne compte pas de ministère
du Travail
de plein exercice!
Alors que la France
traverse une crise
du logement d'une
ampleur inédite,
que le nombre de personnes
sans domicile
a doublé en 10 ans,
que 3000 enfants dorment
dans la rue, que 18%
de la population vit
dans un logement insalubre,
ce gouvernement
ne compte
toujours pas de ministre
du Logement!
Alors qu'en outre-mer,
le taux de chômage
est de 2 à 4
fois plus élevé
que dans l'Hexagone,
que s'y nourrir coûte jusqu'à 40%
plus cher,
que s'y trouvent
les plus grands
déserts médicaux
et que le scandale d'Etat
du chlordécone attend
une réponse
du gouvernement,
toujours pas
de portefeuille
pour ce territoire!
Alors que notre pays
a besoin de mesures choc
pour développer
le transport ferroviaire
dans l'urgence
de la transition écologique,
ce gouvernement
ne compte pas de ministère
du transport!
Alors que l'école
publique connaît
une crise sans précédent,
que près
de 10.000 enseignants
ont disparu
depuis 2017,
que la France poursuit
sa chute vertigineuse
dans les classements,
pas de ministre
de plein exercice
pour l'Education nationale!
Pire: le jour même
de sa nomination,
la ministre en charge
de l'Education nationale,
de la Jeunesse, des Sports,
des Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques vantait
la ségrégation sociale,
humiliant au passage
les enseignants
du public.
Votre passage est clair:
le triomphe
de l'oligarchie est assumée.
Alors que nous devons
agir d'urgence
pour la paix, le ministre
des Affaires étrangères
a pour seul atout
d'avoir grandi à l'étranger
pour l'aider dans sa tâche.
Où sont vos propositions
pour réparer
notre République
abîmée, pour apaiser
notre pays déchiré,
pour répondre
à la souffrance
de la majeure partie
du peuple maltraité?
Face au désespoir
des agriculteurs,
vous avez fait le pari
du coup de com'
sur un ballot de paille.
Nous ne sommes pas convaincus.
Aucune mesure sérieuse
n'a été proposée
pour répondre à la situation
catastrophique
ils affrontent.
Rien de concret
sur les distorsions
de concurrence nourries
par l'importation massive
de produits
qui ne respectent pas
les normes sociales ou sanitaires.
Rien sur les effets des traités
de libre-échange,
seulement un vague
engagement
sur le Mercosur en ignorant
les nombreuses autres négociations
en cours.
Rien sur les prix
planchers
et sur la révision
en profondeur
des négociations commerciales.
On ne dupe pas
impunément
ceux qui ne veulent pas
mourir
pour pouvoir nourrir.
Vous n'allez pas
duper pas
non plus la majorité
des Français
et des Français
qui ne se laisseront
pas impressionner
par une litanie
de mesurettes de court terme.
Ils attendent
des réformes de fond
et de progrès social.
Face à l'inflation
qui atteint 20%
en cumulé sur les 2
dernières années,
avec des pics
encore plus importants
pour les denrées
alimentaires et l'énergie,
face à la smicardisation
de la France,
vous ne proposez
rien pour revoir
de fond en comble
notre système fiscal afin
de garantir une meilleure
répartition
des richesses et de la valeur.
Rien pour réduire
les écarts de revenus!
Rien pour pénaliser
la rente financière
et améliorer
le niveau de vie
de nos concitoyens!
Bien au contraire,
vous nous annoncez poursuivre
dans la casse minutieuse
de notre modèle social.
Vous allez laisser
respirer les entreprises
avec moins de normes,
et étouffer
les chômeurs avec moins de droits!
Vous avez oublié,
comme par hasard,
de rappeler
l'augmentation des prix
de l'électricité
et des franchises médicales.
Je vous le demande
solennellement:
renoncez à ces augmentations.
Face au drame
qui se déroule en Palestine
et alors que la Cour
internationale
de justice a reconnu
le risque de génocide
en cours dans la bande
de Gaza, la France,
comme vous-même,
reste désespérément silencieuse
et complaisante à l'égard
du gouvernement israélien,
ignorant le rôle
que notre pays pourrait jouer
dans cette région
pour retrouver
sa grandeur passée.
Vous persistez dans votre refus
de reconnaître l'Etat palestinien,
à appeler à un cessez-le-feu
permanent,
mais vous vous précipitez
pour suspendre
les aides aux réfugiés
palestiniens
de l'UNWRA.
Le fameux: "deux poids,
deux mesures",
c'est devenu
votre ligne directrice.
N'est-ce pas
vous qui avez inventé
avec votre ministre
de tutelle monsieur
Bruno Le Maire l'obstruction
gouvernementale
pour empêcher l'adoption
de nos propositions
de loi pour indexer les prix
sur l'inflation?
Vous ne nous laissez
que peu d'espoir.
Votre refus de soumettre
votre déclaration
de politique
générale au vote
de la représentation
nationale anéantit
tous vos efforts
déployés à convaincre
des atouts de votre jeunesse
pour diriger
ce gouvernement.
Vous avez la fougue,
mais il vous manque
le courage et le panache.
Pour ce qui concerne
nos députés,
nous resterons fidèles
aux engagements
que nous avons pris
devant les Français
et les Françaises,
dans le combat
entre l'ombre et la lumière.
Nous nous opposerons
au sabotage méthodique
des valeurs qui ont fait
la grandeur
de notre pays
et de notre République
indivisible, laïque,
démocratique
et sociale.
Nous resterons fidèles
à nos pratiques parlementaires,
travaillant sans relâche
sur nos territoires
pour être au plus près
des besoins
et des préoccupations
de celles
et ceux qui souffrent.
Nous allons déployer
toute notre énergie
pour réparer notre nation.
Nous sommes du côté
de l'espérance,
lucide, hors
de toute naïveté,
ce qui nous fait
dire pour conclure:
"Margaret Thatcher,
sortez du corps
de notre Premier ministre."
Quand on est réac, on est réac!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à présent
à monsieur Pancher.
- Bertrand Pancher:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier
ministre, mesdames
et messieurs les ministres,
chers collègues.
Comme la plupart
de mes collègues
du groupe LIOT,
je suis allé
sur un barrage
d'agriculteurs en colère
ces derniers jours
pour leur témoigner
notre solidarité et notre soutien.
Mon passage n'était
ni organisé
par les services
de la préfecture
ni filtré.
Issu d'un territoire rural,
fils d'agriculteur,
ayant à l'esprit
les graves difficultés
qu'ils affrontent,
j'ai vu leur visage grave.
J'ai été frappé
par une colère amplifiée
par l'absence d'écoute
et de concertation.
Après la crise
des gilets jaunes,
celle des retraites,
des banlieues,
cette mobilisation
est encore un appel
à changer les modes de décision.
Vous n'anticipez
jamais
et vous ne savez pas écouter.
Vous êtes dans l'entre-soi
depuis les beaux quartiers
de Paris.
Que nous demandent
nos concitoyens?
Que le travail
paie enfin
et que vous maîtrisiez
l'inflation, touchant
de plus en plus
de Françaises
et de Français.
Ils demandent
aussi une justice
et un accompagnement
social,
et non pas un "Marche ou crève".
De la simplification:
les normes
ont triplé en 20 ans.
On comprend pourquoi
nos hôpitaux,
la justice, l'enseignement,
nos commissariats
sont dans un si mauvais état.
On ne prépare pas l'avenir
de nos jeunes,
y compris au plan environnemental.
Cette crise ne peut
se résoudre
que par une réforme
profonde de l'Etat.
Il faut un véritable choc
de décentralisation,
plus de référendums,
des corps intermédiaires
plus écoutés.
Nous avons des dépenses
publiques
les plus importantes que tous
les pays occidentaux
pour des services publics
qui fonctionnent
de moins en moins bien:
quel paradoxe!
Les Français veulent
des hôpitaux
qui fonctionnent,
des EHPAD
qui ne soient pas
des mouroirs
et de bonnes
écoles
qui ne soit pas réservées
aux plus riches.
Comme le président
s'y est engagé,
nous demandons
une vraie loi adaptée.
Une politique
du logement qui permette
de s'engager enfin
dans la rénovation énergétique.
Nous demandons une loi
de programmation
pour les territoires ultramarins.
Les coupures d'eau
sont insupportables.
Je ne vous ai pas
entendu
non plus sur l'aménagement
des territoires.
Vous venez de prononcer
votre discours
de politique générale
trois semaines
après votre nomination.
Vous oubliez
que vous n'avez
toujours pas de majorité.
Votre gouvernement
n'est
toujours pas constitué.
Vous n'avez pas osé
demander la confiance
de notre assemblée.
Vos déclarations choc,
les surenchères médiatiques
et leur mise en scène
ne sauront contenter
nos concitoyens
à la recherche
d'un cap.
Ils veulent
une méthode claire,
celle de l'écoute
et de la concertation.
Cela fait 7 ans
que vous êtes au pouvoir,
et même
si cela fait 7 ans
que vous êtes au pouvoir,
il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire.
Vous pouvez travailler
sur les priorités
de notre pays
ces trois prochaines années.
Nous y sommes presque.
Il faut y associer tous
les corps intermédiaires
et les forces vives de notre pays.
Nous vous demandons
un calendrier précis
sur les réformes
institutionnelles,
le transfert de compétences
aux grandes collectivités
et leur autonomie fiscale.
C'est la clé
de la réussite
pour la France,
sans oublier la question
de l'autonomie pour la Corse.
Nous croyons
que notre pays
n'est pas ingouvernable,
qu'il est réformable
et qu'il suffit
que vous entendiez enfin
les Français.
Avec le président
Macron,
vous êtes au pied du mur.
La première porte
vous permettra
de monter un à un les escaliers
du redressement
de notre pays.
La deuxième porte
s'ouvre face
à un grand précipice.
Ecoutez les Français
et les Françaises
et ne vous trompez pas de porte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à présent
à monsieur Maillard,
pour le groupe Renaissance.
Applaudissements
Revendications
- Sylvain Maillard:
Je n'ai rien dit, encore.
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier ministre,
mesdames et messieurs
les ministres.
Alors que vous prononcez
votre discours
de politique générale
devant cette Assemblée,
il est clair que 2024 sera
une année décisive.
Pour notre continent,
d'abord,
avec la tenue d'un scrutin
qui déterminera l'Europe
que nous voulons.
Pour notre pays,
ensuite,
alors que les JO
de Paris feront rayonner
la France à travers le monde.
Pour notre avenir
enfin,
puisque les politiques
que nous aurons
à mettre en place
dès maintenant
vont définir le visage
de notre nation
pour les décennies à venir.
C'est dans ce
contexte
que vous avez été nommé,
et cette nomination symbolise
pour les députés
Renaissance autant
une marque
de renouvellement
que de fidélité.
Fidélité à l'égard
de cette majorité parlementaire
dont vous êtes issu.
Cette majorité qui, en 7 ans,
a créé 2 millions d'emplois
et fait de l'objectif
du plein emploi
un but atteignable et non
un voeu impossible.
Cette majorité
est celle qui a entamé
la réindustrialisation
du pays,
avec l'installation de plus de 300
nouvelles usines
sur notre territoire.
Celle qui investit
dans notre souveraineté
énergétique en relançant
la filière nucléaire
et en développant
les énergies
comme jamais auparavant.
Celle qui a permis
un renforcement
des effectifs
de la police
et de la justice
dans des proportions inédites
depuis 30 ans
et redonné à nos armées
les moyens d'assurer
leurs missions
aux quatre coins du globe.
C'est cette majorité
qui a accru
les chances
dans le redoublement
des classes
et l'école inclusive
et qui lutte
contre les déserts médicaux
avec la suppression
du numerus clausus
et la libération du temps médical.
Nous devons aller plus loin.
Vous avez fait
des annonces fortes.
Celles qui ont su
protéger nos concitoyens
et nos entreprises
durant la crise
du Covid-19
comme nous les protégeons
encore aujourd'hui
face à l'inflation,
plus qu'aucun autre pays européen.
Cette majorité
a fait de la France
le premier pays d'Europe en termes
d'investissement
tout en accélérant
la transition écologique,
avec la baisse
de plus de 4%
de nos émissions de CO2 en 2023.
Nous sommes dans la trajectoire.
C'est celle qui a voté
les moyens
de protéger notre souveraineté
alimentaire,
avec les lois Egalim.
J'y reviendrai.
Je pourrais multiplier
les exemples
de notre action
résolue depuis 7 ans
pour libérer,
protéger et transformer
notre pays.
Vous vous inscrivez
dans cette histoire
et vous avez désormais,
avec votre gouvernement,
à en écrire une nouvelle page.
Vous avez d'emblée
voulu vous inscrire
sous le prisme de l'action
et du concret.
C'est une nécessité.
La politique risque
de mourir du paradoxe
de ne pas oser
dire les choses,
d'un côté,
et de l'autre, d'en dire
trop au risque
de se perdre
dans le discours
au détriment des actes.
Plus que tout,
les temps imposent
que nous soyons dans le dire.
Nous partageons le même constat.
Nous attendons
de vous que votre action prenne
en compte la réalisation
du dernier kilomètre,
celui sans lequel
il n'est pas concevable
de pouvoir changer
réellement la vie
des Français.
Vos paroles
devant cette Assemblée
et vos premières
décisions constituent
une preuve
de l'importance
que vous accordez à cet impératif.
Il aura à s'incarner
dans les nombreux domaines
qui définiront
la France de demain.
L'un
des plus essentiels
pour notre pays,
premier producteur européen,
c'est bien sûr l'agriculture.
Dans un monde aux échanges
ultracompétitifs,
nous devons continuer
à défendre l'excellence
des produits
français en imposant
les mêmes normes
de qualité aux pays
qui veulent importer
leurs denrées
chez nous.
Les députés
Renaissance veulent
ces clauses
miroirs
pour qu'il soit impossible
d'importer
des produits
qui ne correspondent
pas à nos normes.
Nous saluons
votre détermination
à les instaurer
dans nos échanges commerciaux.
C'est cette préoccupation
d'une alimentation
de qualité
qui nous a poussés à déposer
une proposition de loi
sur le bien-manger
qui sera votée
dans cette Assemblée
en mars prochain.
Pour que notre agriculture
prospère,
il faut avant tout que ceux qui la
font vivre puissent vivre
de cette activité,
sans craindre
le lendemain.
Pour cela,
en tant que législateurs,
nous ne pouvons tolérer
que les lois votées
par la représentation nationale
soient contournées,
voire bafouées.
Aussi, nous saluons
votre volonté
de faire respecter
par les distributeurs,
les transformateurs
et les industriels
les lois Egalim
ainsi que la loi
que nous avons portée
pour sécuriser l'approvisionnement
des Français en produits
de grande consommation.
Nous serons à vos côtés
pour défendre l'agriculture
et exiger
qu'elle soit rémunérée
à sa juste valeur.
Nous continuerons,
dans les semaines
à venir,
à nous faire le relais
des préoccupations
des maraîchers,
des éleveurs,
des viticulteurs,
des céréaliers
et de l'ensemble
des agriculteurs
et des pêcheurs
de nos territoires.
Pour porter des textes
qui améliorent
le quotidien,
comme la proposition
de loi Renaissance
pour protéger
le mode de vie agricole
face aux troubles
du voisinage...
Dans cette perspective,
nous nous appliquerons
à réussir la future loi
d'orientation agricole
et à apporter des mesures
qui changeront concrètement
et rapidement
la situation
de ceux qui nous nourrissent.
Ce choc des facilités
que nous voulons
pour notre agriculture,
il doit aussi
se faire au bénéfice
de l'ensemble
des concitoyens
et des entreprises
de notre pays, sans oublier
les collectivités locales.
La bureaucratie est un poison
lorsqu'elle alimente
le désordre au lieu
de le résoudre.
A la suite
de la crise du Covid,
nous avons commencé à lever
certaines lenteurs,
à remettre en cause
des procédures
sans logique.
Nous serons évidemment
au rendez-vous
pour amender
et accentuer la loi
de simplification.
Ce chantier
nous permettra de changer
la vie de nos concitoyens
tout en maintenant
notre tactique de redressement
des finances publiques.
La bonne tenue
de nos comptes
est un impératif absolu
de notre majorité.
Nous tiendrons ensemble
le désendettement
que nous nous sommes fixé
jusqu'en 2027.
Plus que tout,
pour permettre
à notre pays de prospérer,
il faut redonner
toute sa pertinence
à la valeur travail,
d'abord en faisant en sorte
que le travail paie
et en refusant
de laisser des millions
de salariés s'enfoncer
dans la précarité.
Nous ne pouvons
tolérer
que ceux qui respectent
notre contrat social
et contribuent chaque jour
à faire tourner
nos entreprises
connaissent les angoisses
des fins de mois.
Cette classe moyenne
qui est le pilier
de notre économie
et qui se sent
trop souvent
la grande oubliée
de nos politiques publiques.
A cet égard,
les mesures
que vous avez annoncées
ici
vont dans le bon sens,
car le travail doit toujours payer
plus que l'inactivité.
Ce combat
pour le travail,
il est au coeur
de ce travail
que les députés
Renaissance défendent
depuis 7 ans.
Il est l'essence de chacun.
Il sera déterminant
pour améliorer durablement
le pouvoir d'achat
des Français,
qui est leur principale
préoccupation
et qui doit donc
être la nôtre, en métropole
comme en outre-mer.
Essentiel aussi
dans cette quête d'émancipation
est l'accès pour tous
à un logement.
Or, la crise que connaît
ce secteur impose
que nous apportions
des réponses fortes
aux Français.
Les textes
que notre groupe a portés
ces derniers mois,
qu'il s'agisse
de la proposition
contre l'occupation illicite
ou celle sur les meublés
touristiques, constituent
des premières briques.
Nous voulons un véritable
choc de l'offre.
Un autre impératif,
un droit fondamental,
même, c'est le droit
à la sécurité.
Aucun habitant
ne devrait craindre
de se promener
dans son quartier,
aucune femme
ne devrait craindre
de rentrer seule
le soir, aucun citoyen
ne devrait être victime
d'incivilités, voire
de violence dans l'espace public.
Aucun Français
ne devrait craindre
de représailles
du simple fait
de sa confession.
A tous, nous devons
leur assurer,
quelle que soit
leur résidence,
quel que soit leur genre
ou quelle que soit leur religion,
qu'ils puissent
vivre en paix
dans leur pays.
Les députés Renaissance
y contribueront
dès ce printemps
avec une proposition
de loi renforçant
la réponse pénale
contre les infractions
à caractère raciste
ou antisémite
et une autre, allongeant
la durée de l'ordonnance
de protection
pour les victimes
de violences conjugales.
J'ai énuméré les chantiers
de court terme.
Je n'oublie pas
ceux qui ont vocation
à s'inscrire
dans le temps long
car ils sont le fondement
même
de notre identité.
Parmi eux, le premier est l'école.
C'est auprès
des jeunes générations
que se joue notre avenir.
Les jeunes
générations
à qui vous avez d'emblée
dit
que vous vouliez redonner
des causes d'espérance.
Nous ne pouvons qu'y souscrire.
Pour cela, l'école
est primordiale.
Pour lui redonner
toute sa place,
nous ne devons jamais
hésiter à bousculer
les schémas
quand ils sont imparfaits
et à donner les moyens
à nos établissements
de valoriser ce qui fonctionne.
Cet investissement
du politique,
il faut
qu'il se traduise
dans tous les services
publics, partout
sur le territoire,
notamment en matière
de santé.
La première cause
du sentiment d'abandon
de beaucoup,
c'est le manque d'accès
aux soins.
Je l'ai dit,
notre majorité a déjà agi
pour inverser la tendance.
Comme vous l'avez
souligné
dans votre discours,
il nous faudra
accentuer cet effort.
Nous serons à vos côtés pour cela.
Un autre défi
de notre temps,
le plus grand sans doute,
c'est le changement climatique.
Vous avez,
en responsabilité,
exposé la planification
écologique.
Ce sera essentiel
pour promouvoir
une écologie de l'innovation
et de solutions plutôt qu'une
écologie de l'obligation.
Ecologie doit rimer avec ambition.
Ecologie ne doit jamais rimer
avec décroissance.
Nous ne devons pas
abandonner
notre ambition écologique,
mais celle-ci
ne doit jamais
se faire au détriment
des Français.
Il faut aussi
redonner aux citoyens
le goût de l'engagement.
C'est ce que notre majorité
s'emploie
à faire en votant
cette semaine la proposition
de loi visant à soutenir
l'engagement bénévole
ainsi que la proposition
de loi visant
à reconnaître les métiers
de la médiation sociale.
Votre décision de pérenniser
les cours d'éducation civique
à l'école constitue également
un signe extrêmement encourageant,
de même
que la généralisation
du SNU que vous venez d'annoncer.
Ce besoin d'engagement
se fait aussi sentir
dans notre démocratie.
Cela impose
de revaloriser
ceux qui la font vivre.
Il n'est pas concevable
que,
dans notre pays,
les élus soient impunément l'objet
d'insultes, de menaces,
de violences,
pour ne pas dire de lynchages.
Servir ses concitoyens
au sein
de sa commune,
de son département,
de sa région
ou dans cette Assemblée
ne devrait jamais
faire craindre
pour sa vie ou pour celle
de ses proches.
Une démocratie
qui se retourne
contre ceux qui
la servent,
elle se détruit.
Honte à ceux qui,
par leur comportement outrancier,
ont pu, y compris
sur ces bancs, alimenter
ces bas instincts.
A cet égard, la proposition
de loi renforçant
la sécurité des élus
locaux sera salutaire.
Le retour de l'autorité
passe nécessairement
par le respect
envers les institutions
et leurs représentants.
Pour mener à bien
toutes ces entreprises,
l'esprit de compromis qui exige
la configuration
de notre Assemblée
apparaît indispensable.
Je le redis
aujourd'hui
devant tous les groupes
de l'arc républicain,
ma main et celle
des députés Renaissance
est toujours tendue
pour construire
des majorités de projet.
Nous le faisons déjà à travers
plusieurs textes transpartisans.
Il nous faut accentuer cet élan.
Pour conduire
toutes ces réformes,
un autre élément
consubstantiel au projet
que nous portons depuis 2017
apparaît essentiel.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, la France
a besoin d'audace
pour tenir le rang
qui est le sien
dans le concert
des nations et en Europe,
pour protéger l'art
de vivre à la française
et faire valoir
ses idéaux face
aux bouleversements
du monde,
pour se réinventer sans cesse
en accord avec son histoire
et ses valeurs.
Parce que votre action
tend à s'inscrire
dans la République d'une France
fière d'elle-même,
je veux vous assurer
ici du soutien
et de la confiance
des députés Renaissance.
Pour terminer
mon propos, monsieur
le Premier ministre,
je veux vous lancer cet appel,
le même que Danton fit
jadis à la tribune:
"De l'audace,
encore de l'audace,
et la France est sauvée!"
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le président.
Protestations et applaudissements
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
la présidente
Le Pen pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Marine Le Pen:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
mesdames et messieurs,
chers collègues,
l'exercice auquel nous venons
d'assister tient
du rituel.
Il est presque mécanique.
Il l'est plus encore aujourd'hui.
C'est un catalogue,
une succession
de promesses
diverses et variées
sans lien
entre elles et de niveaux
pour le moins inégaux,
ce qui est assez éloigné
d'un discours
de politique générale.
Ce n'est pas faire
injure à monsieur
le Premier ministre
de constater
que son intervention
n'est que la revue
de détail d'une déclaration
de politique générale
que le président
de la République
avait faite avant
lui et à sa place,
à l'occasion d'une conférence
de presse fleuve.
Vous comme nous,
et surtout comme le pays,
subissons l'intempérance
jupitérienne.
Il est vrai que le nouvel
équilibre institutionnel
du quinquennat
a trop souvent ravalé
le rôle du Premier
ministre
à celui d'un simple figurant,
un communiquant,
un collaborateur,
comme dirait un ancien président.
Avec Emmanuel Macron,
cette atrophie institutionnelle
reste encore plus aggravée
par la conception autocentrée
qu'il se fait du pouvoir.
Le président
est ministre de tout,
et évidemment
le premier d'entre eux.
Pour aller
directement au fait,
je n'ai pas vu dans ce discours
de politique générale,
qui tombe d'une
des fenêtres du château,
les voies et moyens
de redressement.
Je n'ai pas senti
le grand souffle
qui puisse
emporter le pays
vers des lendemains heureux,
et je n'ai senti
aucun souffle.
Il ne suffit pas d'invoquer
une volonté
de mettre fin
au conservatisme
pour bousculer
un système sclérosé
par des décennies
de politiquement correct,
de connivence,
de bétonnage pas toujours
nécessaire.
Vous n'y
êtes pas parvenus,
mais au contraire,
vous poursuivez
un système oligarchique
dont votre ministre,
madame Oudéa-Castéra,
apparaît
comme l'exemple archétypal.
Cela ne nous laisse
entrevoir qu'une réponse
à quelques urgences
médiatiques,
comme s'il s'agissait
de gagner du temps.
Je ne vois rien qui contribue
au redressement
des piliers effondrés.
Vous continuez à apporter
une vision utilitariste
autour de mesures
sans transcendance
et une vision fondamentalement
post-politique
et post-nationale.
Dans ce catalogue,
vous tentez d'allier
un peu de droite
et un peu de gauche.
Vous rassemblez
le pire de la droite
et le pire de la gauche.
Le pire de la droite,
c'est par exemple
la hausse des franchises
médicales
ou la nouvelle réforme
à venir du chômage.
Le pire de la gauche,
la hausse
des taxes sur l'électricité
ou la normalisation
à outrance,
je pense au DPE
qui fait du mal au logement.
Le bilan financier
de vos politiques
est apparu
il y a quelques jours:
un déficit du budget
sans équivalent.
Il faut un mouvement appuyé
sur la force retrouvée
de l'Etat et sur une volonté
populaire
qui légitime l'action publique.
La souveraineté,
l'Etat, la démocratie.
La première condition
est de rendre
au pays sa capacité de décider.
Votre arrimage aveugle
et inconditionnel
sur l'agenda bruxellois
vous condamne d'office
aux mêmes errements
que vos prédécesseurs.
A quoi riment les discours
sur le volontarisme lorsque
vous savez
que vous avez laissé
les commandes intellectuelles
et institutionnelles
à l'autorité supranationale
de l'Union européenne?
A quoi bon la déclaration
sur l'agriculture,
au-dessus de tout,
quand vous êtes prisonniers
des logiques du wokisme vert?
Appuyé sur des ballots
de paille,
vous parlez
de souveraineté française,
quand l'Elysée use
et abuse d'un oxymore,
d'une incantation antinomique,
la souveraineté européenne,
alors que la très mercantile
Union européenne
a depuis toujours
révoqué le mot
de souveraineté
pour s'en remettre
de manière obsessionnelle
à la seule loi
du marché.
Pensez qu'au moment même
où les agriculteurs français
manifestaient
à Bruxelles
devant le Parlement
européen,
à quelques mètres de là,
dans un immeuble
en verre, vos élus du groupe
Renaissance votaient
un nouvel accord
de libre-échange désastreux
avec le Chili!
Cela ne vous empêchait pas,
le lendemain,
la main sur le coeur,
de promettre
aux agriculteurs français
de les défendre.
Les commentateurs
amusés y verraient
les artifices du "en même temps".
Ces faux-semblants
m'inspirent
la plus grande peine
pour nos agriculteurs,
pour cette France
rurale qui souffre,
pour notre peuple que l'on trompe.
La confiance,
pourtant si nécessaire
en ces temps de crise,
ne peut revenir
dans votre monde
où on privilégiera
le court terme,
l'apparence, l'éphémère,
et où on pense
pouvoir éteindre
les contestations
par le mensonge,
la ruse ou l'usure.
Il ne sert à rien
de vouloir écoper
le bateau qui fait eau
quand les membres
de l'équipage s'activent
en même temps
à ouvrir des voies
d'eau partout
dans la coque.
Quel crédit peut-on accorder
à ces incohérences?
Avez-vous
seulement prise
sur ce qui se passe,
sur ce qui est décidé,
sur ce système qui a fait
le choix résolu
de la vassalisation à Bruxelles?
Vos choix politiques
ressemblent
de plus en plus à un pacte
faustien.
Il s'agit peut-être
seulement de gagner
un peu plus de temps
de jouissance.
Il est parfois
compliqué de comprendre
ce qu'est le macronisme.
Vraisemblablement,
beaucoup d'observateurs avertis
seraient incapables
d'en donner
une définition précise.
Une chose est sûre:
il s'agit d'une pensée liquide
avec, pour perspective,
une société liquide.
Pour vous,
tout doit se résumer
à des flux.
La théorie
du ruissellement vous sert
à servir les nantis.
Le seul ruissellement
qu'il y a eu
est celui de l'argent
public qui a coulé
à flot.
900 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires
en 7 ans!
Autant que le montant total
de la dette française
pour l'an 2000!
Cette liquidité
que vous prônez mène
à la liquidation.
Emmanuel Macron
en tête, vous mettez
en oeuvre la grande
déconstruction,
le grand effacement
de la France
comme des somnambules,
sans tenir compte
des réalités sociales
ou de l'évolution
du monde qui s'ajoute
à l'abrasion naturelle
du temps, quand rien
dans la décision politique
ne conduise au dépassement.
La première condition,
c'était la souveraineté.
La seconde condition,
c'est la restauration
de l'Etat.
Je ne vois pas
dans votre déclaration
de lueur d'espoir.
La restauration
de l'Etat suppose
de sortir de la grande confusion
politico-administrative
qui règne dans nos institutions
nationales
ou locales.
Il faut remettre de l'ordre
dans l'organisation publique.
Avec le gouvernement
des sachants,
on assiste à un va-et-vient
entre fonction administrative
et fonction politique,
entre fonction publique
et intérêts privés,
entre fonction élective
et autres magistratures.
Il en résulte une confusion
sur la crédibilité
des institutions.
Confusion politique
lorsque les politiques
ont appliqué
leurs responsabilités
et que le mot
"politique" en vient
à signifier impuissance.
Qui décide de quoi?
Qui est en état de décider?
Le local?
Le national?
Le Parlement?
Le président?
Le juge?
Le Conseil constitutionnel?
Bruxelles?
L'OTAN?
Le président ne préside pas,
il gouverne.
Lorsque le président gouverne,
le gouvernement
se contente d'administrer
les affaires courantes.
Que dire des régions
qui ouvrent
des ambassades à l'étranger,
des communes
qui subventionnent sans honte
le trafic d'êtres humains
par le biais
d'associations complices
des passeurs,
des clans politiques
qui saccagent
la capitale
de tous les Français,
d'un préfet
de police qui est incapable
de faire cesser
les vendeurs à la sauvette
sous la tour Eiffel
ou d'une préfecture
qui entretient
des rapports troubles
avec des organisations illégales?
La question
qui est posée au pays
n'est pas seulement
le programme
de tel ou tel gouvernement.
Ce n'est pas la vision de tel
ou tel président.
Ce n'est pas la bonne
volonté supposée
ou réelle de tel ou tel ministre.
C'est le retour du politique!
C'est au politique
qu'il appartient
de décider,
et tout particulièrement
dans les ministères,
dans les assemblées,
dans les communes.
L'élu doit arrêter
de se tourner
vers le fonctionnaire
pour se faire souffler
une décision.
Les ministres
doivent cesser
d'être les porte-parole
serviles
des directeurs
d'administration,
des féodalités bancaires
et de la grande distribution.
Ils doivent redevenir
les inspirateurs
des grandes
impulsions publiques
dont le pays a besoin.
Le retour du politique,
c'est aussi congédier
la pensée magique,
celle du "il suffit d'emprunter",
celle des grands prêtres
de la pensée unique.
A l'heure où vous parlez
de réarmement
pour vous donner
des airs guerriers,
je ne crois pas avoir entendu
l'expression "réarmement
régalien".
Ce n'est pas
un oubli
car ce n'est pas votre projet.
Pourtant, la question
est d'importance.
La France est-elle
condamnée à s'enfoncer
dans le laxisme judiciaire?
La politique peut-elle
encore continuer
à demander au politique
de terrain
les solutions
sécuritaires et sociales
qui relèvent justement
du politique,
et de lui seul?
L'entreprise peut-elle
combler les carences
de formation, et parfois
même d'éducation?
Pour reprendre
le cardinal de Richelieu:
"La politique revient
à rendre possible
ce qui est nécessaire.
Cela exige de la persévérance."
Le retour du politique
implique en réalité
la détermination
à reprendre le contrôle,
à le reprendre sur les forces
supranationales,
comme l'Union européenne,
des féodalités
qui gangrènent la vie
sociale et économique,
sur les inerties administratives.
Le moyen de cette reprise
de contrôle,
c'est l'Etat, pour peu
qu'il soit respecté,
c'est-à-dire restauré.
La restauration
de l'Etat,
c'est la réhabilitation des grands
corps préfectoraux
ou diplomatiques,
le retour du sens
de l'Etat et au plus près
des gens, partout
sur le terrain,
avec la proximité
des services publics.
C'est un état
conscient
qui n'agit pas pour lui,
mais au service
de la nation,
un Etat conscient
que son premier devoir
est la sécurité intérieure
et extérieure,
l'égalité des citoyens
et la liberté de tous!
C'est un Etat dont les agents
sont honorés, respectés
et récompensés,
comme le service
qu'ils consacrent au pays.
C'est un Etat
doté des moyens
de ses missions.
La troisième condition
du redressement,
c'est la démocratie,
le retour du peuple
ou de ses représentants.
Quoi que vous puissiez
dire
sur votre changement
de méthode,
on ne peut que constater
votre incapacité
à sortir des logiques verticales.
A votre décharge,
après 7 ans de pouvoir d'Emmanuel
Macron,
je ne crois pas que vous puissiez
modifier ce qui est une marque
de fabrique
du macronisme.
Votre discours sonnait
comme un réquisitoire
des 7 ans d'Emmanuel Macron.
Vous n'avez pas de majorité.
Au lieu d'en chercher
une par le respect
de vos alliés
et par l'écoute,
vous comptez sur des ruses
institutionnelles
en excluant par principe
les voix transparentes
et saines.
L'élaboration de la loi
par des 49.3,
les décisions
publiques au marteau
ou les atteintes
aux droits
ne sont pas admissibles
dans une démocratie moderne.
Lorsque le Conseil
constitutionnel participe
au détricotement
de la représentation
parlementaire,
il en ressort une impression
de déni démocratique,
un piétinement
du principe de la démocratie.
Qui peut croire que le délit
de séjour irrégulier n'aurait rien
à voir avec l'immigration
et devrait
être effacé de la loi?
Le respect de la volonté
du peuple,
le fondement
de la démocratie,
nul ne devrait pouvoir
s'en affranchir!
Vous devez cesser
de considérer l'exercice
de la démocratie
comme une formalité
administrative,
la conduite de l'Etat
comme un passe-temps,
les institutions
comme des instruments,
les fonctions ministérielles
comme un jeu de chaises musicales.
Ce que nous attendons
d'un gouvernement,
c'est qu'il définisse
clairement
la grande voie autour de laquelle
doit s'articuler
toute action publique,
toute projection
pour l'avenir.
Nous n'avons rien
vu de tout cela,
ni depuis 7 ans, ni aujourd'hui!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
La présidente Panot.
- Mathilde Panot:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier ministre,
chers collègues.
Vous nous avez maintenus
dans l'attente.
Plus de deux semaines avant de
vous entendre délivrer
un discours
de politique générale
que vous devez
à la représentation nationale.
Vous ne demandez pas
la confiance
de l'Assemblée,
ce qui serait le minimum
à attendre si notre démocratie
fonctionnait.
Vous ne demandez pas
la confiance
car vous n'avez
ni la confiance de l'Assemblée
ni celle des citoyens.
Vous nous avez maintenus
dans l'attente
mais vous vous êtes rendu
compte entre-temps
que personne ne vous attendait.
Avez-vous dit
aux agriculteurs
que votre majorité
avait rejeté
une loi
que nous avions proposée
en novembre dernier
pour encadrer
les marges de l'industrie
agroalimentaire
et leur garantir
des prix rémunérateurs?
Leur avez-vous parlé
de votre duplicité
ou vous êtes-vous
contenter d'une mise
en scène poussive
sur une botte de foin
et un verre de rouge?
Vous venez de démontrer
que votre communication politique
ne va pas plus loin
que votre discours
de propagande générale.
Les professeurs
vont être en grève,
épuisés par vos mesures
et intérêts
par le gouvernement.
La ministre
elle est à elle seule
un symbole
de votre gouvernement,
de votre politique
passée et à venir.
Oligarchie,
haute bourgeoisie,
vous y voilà.
Fils du directeur
de publiciste, cousine
d'un éditorialiste
de BFM TV, présidente
de la Fédération
Française de Tennis
pour 500.000 euros
par an avant de devenir ministre
des Sports puis plus récemment
de l'Education nationale,
des Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques.
La pauvre nous le dit:
elle gagnait 3 fois
plus qu'avant.
Merci de nous avoir offert
une si belle caricature
de votre oligarchie.
Quand on lui parle
de sa défense lamentable
et de ses mensonges
à répétition,
elle dit ne pas avoir menti.
Tenez-vous bien,
c'est la réalité
qui lui donne tort!
En la matière,
vous êtes des experts.
En matière d'économie
sociale, la réalité
vous donne
toujours tort,
mais vous continuez.
Vous mentez de nouveau,
vous continuez.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
madame Amélie
Oudéa-Castéra partage
avec vous un arrondissement
et l'Ecole alsacienne.
Vous vous comprenez bien,
entre bourgeois.
Vous êtes comme elle,
sans doute doit-elle vivre
son ministère
comme une peine infinie
car elle gagne moins qu'à
la Fédération Française
de Tennis.
Peut-être les effets
cumulés de suppression
de l'impôt
sur la fortune venue
de votre part
compense-t-elle
cette baisse de revenus.
Le nom "ministère"
vient de "serviteur",
en latin.
Vous êtes un gouvernement
de serviteur,
sans aucun doute.
Mais en démocratie,
c'est le peuple
que les ministres doivent servir.
Au lieu de cela,
vous vous servez vous-même
ainsi que les riches.
La fortune
des 500 familles
les plus riches
de ce pays
a plus que doublé depuis 2017.
Vous êtes les serviteurs
zélés
mais vous oubliez
la République
et ses principes.
Vous préférez
jeter en pâture
celles
et ceux qui arrivent
sur notre territoire
pour ne pas parler
des inégalités
croissantes, du problème
du logement,
des travailleurs
dont la paie ne suffit plus,
de la situation insupportable
socialement
que vos politiques font subir
aux pays.
Vous n'êtes ni à la hauteur
de la situation sociale
ni de notre histoire
démocratique,
et encore moins à la hauteur
de l'immense défi écologique
qui nous attend.
Vous n'êtes pas à la hauteur.
Une partie de la presse publie
des portraits ridicules
de vous,
où l'on s'extasie du fait
que vous dormiez peu.
C'est peut-être
pour cela que le pays semble
conduit par une équipe
de somnambules,
ensommeillés dans le rêve
de milliardaire,
éblouis par les lumières
télévisuels, vivant
dans un spectacle
permanent
que les Français regardent
avec consternation.
Le pays souffre.
Vos tentatives d'hypnose
ne fonctionnent pas.
Les agriculteurs
à bout comprennent
que le libre-échange,
les marges
sans contrôle
sont la source
de leurs difficultés quotidiennes.
Les enseignants
voient se créer
vos groupes
de niveaux, aussi
stigmatisants qu'inefficaces,
et comprennent
le caractère systématique
de la destruction
du service public.
Les cheminots
que vous avez vilipendés voit
disparaître un petit peu
le service public ferroviaire
que vous avez détruit
méthodiquement
pour libéraliser le rail.
Les salariés du privé
souffrent davantage
du partage injuste
de la valeur produite.
Les soignants et professionnels
du secteur médico-social
constatent
votre obstination à mettre
en pièces le service
public de la santé.
Les chômeurs
pâtissent à chacune
de vos réformes
de la situation économique
qui leur laisse le choix
entre la précarité
ou la honte que vos discours
d'exclusion renvoient toujours.
Les jeunes
pour le climat voient
votre incompréhension à prendre
en compte l'ampleur
des changements nécessaires.
Les retraités
s'inquiètent des coups
de canif que vous avez mis
dans le contrat social
qui lie
entre elles les générations.
Vous refusez
d'engager le partage
des richesses
pour rémunérer le travail.
Engagez les investissements
nécessaires
pour la bifurcation écologique!
Reconstruisez
nos services publics!
Vous déstabilisez notre société.
Vous êtes bien
loin de la République sociale.
Vous resterez
dans l'histoire
comme le pouvoir
qui aura mené la France
à sa fin,
où les gens meurent
sur des brancards d'hôpitaux.
Vous nous avez fait attendre,
mais personne n'attend
plus rien de vous.
Une alternative existe.
Il est possible d'engager
une autre politique:
augmenter le SMIC
à 1600 euros net,
porter l'âge
de la retraite à 60 ans
pour 40 annuités,
investir massivement
dans l'énergie publique,
dans un pôle public
de l'énergie
ou encore la formation
et l'installation
de nouveaux paysans.
Nous pouvons annuler la dette
des agriculteurs.
Tout cela est possible.
Je vous entends déjà demander
comment financer cela.
C'est simple:
en cessant de servir
ceux que vous servez,
en taxant le capital,
en créant de nouvelles
tranches d'impôt
sur le revenu
pour les plus riches
de notre pays,
en rendant possible
la contribution généralisée.
En un mot:
en organisant le partage
des richesses.
Cette perspective doit
vous sembler abominable,
mais c'est la clé
de la cohésion
du pays.
Vous abusez des pouvoirs
que vous donne
la Constitution.
La Ve République
vous rend plus invisible
que vous ne le souhaiteriez,
monsieur
le Premier ministre.
Personne n'ignore
que tout se décide
à l'Elysée, jusqu'à
votre discours
qui a été corrigé et relu
par le monarque lui-même.
Emmanuel Macron,
vous êtes à ses ordres,
comme une bonne partie
de la minorité parlementaire
qui a cru bon
de voter,
il y a quelques semaines,
une loi reprenant
le principe de préférence
nationale défendue
par Jean-Marie Le Pen
et ses héritiers siégeant
sur ces bancs.
Certaines
dispositions devaient
être votées car elles étaient
anticonstitutionnelles
et seraient donc
censurées par la suite.
Vous vous rendez compte
du caractère planant
de certains de vos arguments?
Ne croyez-vous pas qu'un
tel mépris
pour nos règles
communes est le signe
d'un affaiblissement
de nos institutions?
Cela nous invite
à mettre sur la table
un changement institutionnel.
Une autre République
est possible
pour nous et avec la République
sociale,
avec notre belle
devise "Liberté,
égalité, fraternité".
Il est temps de rédiger
la Constitution
de la VIe République.
La République du référendum
qui permettrait
aux Français
de retourner aux urnes
alors que vous le leur refusez
toujours.
Une République
où les ministres servent
le peuple,
et pas une oligarchie
de plus en plus déconnectée.
Vivement un nouveau
gouvernement
et le retour
à la démocratie
dont notre pays a besoin.
Nous préparons
l'alternative
à votre monde de malheur.
Emportez avec vous en guise
d'avertissement
cette phrase du philosophe
Maurice Merleau-Ponty:
"Le pouvoir
que l'on appelle légitime
est celui qui réussit
à éviter le mépris
et la haine."
Vous n'avez réussi
à éviter ni l'un
ni l'autre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Merci, madame la présidente.
La parole est à présent
à monsieur
le président Marleix
pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Merci.
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier ministre,
chers collègues.
Au fond, la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel rayant
d'un trait de plume
le travail du Parlement
sur la loi immigration
et la crise
des agriculteurs nous racontent
la même histoire:
celle des injonctions
que le peuple français
ne supporte
plus de subir de la part
de juges supranationaux,
nationaux,
de technocrates
européens ayant
tous en commun
de ne jamais
avoir de comptes
à rendre aux Français.
Si la souveraineté
nationale peut
à ce point être évitée,
basculée, bafouée,
comment s'étonner
que la politique laisse
à penser aux yeux
des Français
qu'elle est devenue une farce?
Comment s'étonner
qu'ils en viennent
à vouloir renverser la table?
Dans ce moment critique
de notre histoire,
dans cette démocratie en crise,
chacun doit agir
avec plus de sens
des responsabilités
que jamais.
Sur l'immigration,
les Français exigent
un sursaut,
vous leur livrez un tour
de passe-passe.
Les Français n'en peuvent
plus des discours creux,
de vos catalogues
de promesses jamais tenues.
Vous osez nous dire
que depuis 2017,
vous avez défendu
la souveraineté industrielle?
Quelle plaisanterie!
Vous avez vendu nombre
d'entreprises françaises!
Comment vous croire?
Vous parlez
d'alléger le fardeau
des normes pour les agriculteurs?
Au Salon de l'agriculture,
votre prédécesseur
avait déjà promis la fin
de la surtransposition
des normes
environnementales
il y a plus d'un an.
Votre administration
élabore des cartes
de protection
qui vont concerner 30%
de nos surfaces agricoles.
Voilà comment vous trompez
les cultivateurs.
Ce n'est pas
en supprimant
quelques arrêtés
préfectoraux
que vous allez changer
quoi que ce soit.
Vous nous aviez promis
des prix de rémunération
avec Egalim.
Lactalis propose
aux producteurs
de lait un prix
de 40 centimes
quand le prix de revient
est de 48 centimes.
Nous avons voté,
il y a un an, un calcul
plus favorable
pour la retraite
des agriculteurs.
Vous faites
tout pour que cette loi
ne soit pas appliquée.
Il y a huit mois,
nous avons voté ici
une résolution demandant
au gouvernement
de s'opposer à la ratification
du Mercosur.
Il aura fallu
attendre hier
pour que le président
de la République,
pris de panique
dans un Paris assiégé,
demande enfin à madame von
der Leyen d'arrêter
les négociations.
On nous dit que le président
Macron serait désormais prêt
à partir en croisade
contre les 4%
de jachères de la PAC.
Pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas fait
plus tôt?
La chaise vide
du général De Gaulle
se faisait plus entendre
que la chaise pleine
du général Macron.
La politique,
ce n'est pas un catalogue
sans queue
ni tête,
ce n'est pas du théâtre.
C'est le sort de notre pays.
Vous nous avez dit vouloir mettre
l'agriculture au-dessus
de tout.
J'ai eu envie d'y croire.
Je me suis souvenu ensuite
que la semaine d'avant,
c'était l'hôpital
qui était la priorité absolue,
et la semaine d'avant,
c'était l'école.
La semaine prochaine,
ce sera autre chose,
et tant pis pour l'agriculture.
Sur la crise agricole
comme sur l'immigration,
les Français
ne vont pas se contenter d'une
story sur Instagram
ou d'une vidéo TikTok
autour d'une botte de paille.
Ils veulent des résultats
dans la vraie vie.
Tant que les réponses
ne seront
pas là,
nous ne vous lâcherons pas.
Après 7 ans d'agitation
et à coups d'annonces choc,
il ne s'est rien passé.
Vous êtes passé
sur les malheurs
du pays
comme sur des courants d'eau.
Après 7 ans
de pouvoir absolu
à vous écouter,
vous semblez seulement découvrir
le pays, mais les crises
se succèdent.
Le pays est fracturé, révolté.
Ces crises, comme celle
des gilets jaunes,
ont en commun
que vous ne les voyiez jamais
venir
car vous n'êtes pas dans la vraie
vie des Français.
Votre politique
n'enthousiasme
que ceux qui n'attendent
rien
de la politique.
La France
qui a le plus besoin
d'un pouvoir
qui la protège face
à la concurrence déloyale,
agriculteurs, ouvriers,
patrons de petites
industries, la France
qui a besoin
de services publics,
la France qui n'a
plus de médecins,
la France
qui a besoin d'ordre,
qui a besoin
que l'on enferme les dealers
qui menacent
ses enfants,
vous ne la voyez pas
et vous la laissez s'enfoncer
dans la colère.
Comment s'en étonner
de la part
d'un président
pour qui il y a les Français
qui ont réussi
et ceux qui ne sont rien?
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
derrière la communication,
la réalité,
c'est l'échec.
Les résultats sont là.
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
aura marqué
de son empreinte
ou plutôt de ses emprunts
son passage au ministère
des Finances, creusant
avec assiduité
une dette abyssale
de plus de 3000 milliards d'euros.
Ce sont 900
milliards d'euros
de plus qu'à la fin
du quinquennat
de François Hollande.
Le déficit est de 173
milliards d'euros.
Vous dites que vous faire preuve
d'une responsabilité exemplaire
en matière de finances
publiques,
mais de qui vous moquez-vous?
La croissance est en berne.
Le pouvoir d'achat
des Français
est encore un peu plus attaqué
par l'inflation.
Les années
que vous aurez perdues
par vos errements
sur le nucléaire,
à faire du suivisme
derrière les écologistes,
vous placent
dans la situation aberrante
où vous allez
augmenter la facture
des ménages et,
en même temps, faire perdre
à nos entreprises
leurs derniers avantages
de compétitivité.
Au ministère
de l'Intérieur,
monsieur Darmanin
a accueilli près
de 500.000 étrangers par an.
C'est deux fois
plus que sous monsieur Sarkozy.
Quant
à l'insécurité,
nous en sommes à 362.000
plaintes
pour coups et blessures
en 2023, 60%
de plus qu'en 2017.
Depuis 50 ans, la France n'a
jamais enregistré autant
d'homicides ou de tentatives
d'homicides, magnifique record
pour votre gouvernement.
En matière d'éducation,
la France s'effondre
au classement Pisa.
Vous êtes au pouvoir
depuis 7 ans,
c'est votre bilan.
Vous avez créé
une crise du logement
sans précédent.
On ne construit plus.
Les Français
ont de plus en plus de difficultés
à accéder à la propriété.
Votre système MaPrimeRénov'
réussit l'exploit
de rendre les travaux
d'isolation inaccessibles
aux classes moyennes
jugées "trop riches"
et aux foyers
les plus modestes,
incapables de financer
des rénovations globales.
Cette crise est telle
que l'on voit
en France, en 2024,
des salariés dormir
dans leur voiture.
Quand vous nous parlez
de choc, d'offres
de simplification des normes
et d'accélération
des procédures,
permettez-nous de penser
que c'est un peu court.
Le bilan des années
Macron, c'est aussi
un constant affaiblissement
de la parole
de la France à l'international.
Cette singularité
française se résume
à des paroles
maladroites, des coups
de com' sans lendemain
du président
de la République,
en décrédibilisant
les combats au Liban,
inaudibles
en Ukraine.
Quelque chose s'est
brisé de l'image
de notre pays aux yeux du monde.
Vous nous auriez demandé
notre confiance,
nous n'aurions pas pu
vous la donner,
évidemment,
mais nous ne vous empêcherons
pas d'agir.
Sans soutien,
les rares efforts
de notre pays,
retraite, chômage,
RSA, n'auraient pas vu le jour.
Nous vous pressons
d'agir sans délai
pour les agriculteurs,
pour reprendre
le contrôle
de notre immigration,
pour faire
respecter la loi
de la République partout
sur notre territoire.
Nous l'avons compris,
ce remaniement ministériel vise
davantage à infléchir
le cours des sondages
que de l'histoire.
Ce n'est
pourtant pas la communication
qui fera la réussite
de ce gouvernement,
mais sa capacité
à écouter et respecter
les Français
et leurs attentes,
Français
que nous représentons
tous ici, dans cet hémicycle.
Dans l'intérêt du pays,
tâchez de faire mieux
que ce qui vous a été demandé
par votre président.
La durée de vie
de votre gouvernement
ne dépend pas
que du président
de la République mais aussi de cet
Assemblée nationale,
où vous êtes minoritaire
et dont vous n'aurez
pas la confiance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Notre pays est en crise.
Les Français
sont plus que jamais
en attente
de réponses concrètes
à leurs préoccupations,
sans postures politiciennes
mais avec des actes.
La première
de ces préoccupations
est la santé.
On peut saluer certaines
mesures, notamment
le Ségur de la santé,
mais la transformation
du numerus clausus
n'a rien changé
à l'offre de soin,
qui reste totalement insuffisante
dans un grand nombre
de nos territoires.
Cela fait des années
que les députés
de notre groupe
vous alertent
sur la question.
L'hôpital public
est en crise, la médecine
de ville est en crise.
Tout notre système
de santé se délabre.
Pourtant,
des situations simples
sont envisageables.
La passerelle
que vous avez proposé
pour les infirmières
est intéressante,
mais nous vous proposons aussi
de favoriser l'intégration
en études de médecine
et d'augmenter drastiquement
le nombre d'étudiants.
Il s'agit également
de mieux valoriser
les personnels de santé,
cheville indispensable
à la qualité des soins
et à l'accompagnement
dans la dignité de nos aînés.
L'autre grand chantier,
l'Education nationale.
Toutes les inégalités
doivent être traitées,
notamment
dans les territoires ruraux
qui voient des classes
fermer, tandis
qu'elles ont été
dédoublées
dans les REP et REP+.
Il faut, dans une logique
d'équivalence, baisser
les seuils amenant
à la fermeture
de classes en zone rurale.
Le manque
d'attractivité
dans cette profession
est marquée
par une nouvelle baisse en 2024
du nombre d'inscrits
au concours externe
par rapport à 2023.
La perte de pouvoir
d'achat subie
par les enseignants
depuis plus de 20 ans
est une raison sur laquelle
il faut continuer
à avancer.
Toujours sur la partie
éducation,
et pour une véritable
inclusion scolaire,
il faut drastiquement augmenter
le nombre d'AESH.
Notre environnement
proche est marqué
par de fortes instabilités.
Notre pays doit continuer
à faire entendre
et respecter sa voix singulière.
Il doit défendre l'autonomie
stratégique européenne.
Un beau défi
international
est devant nous,
celui de la bonne organisation
des JO, et donc
de leur sécurisation.
La mobilisation des forces
de l'ordre sera cruciale.
Sur cette question
sécuritaire,
tous nos territoires sont touchés.
Nous l'avons vu
lors des émeutes
de juin dernier.
Attention
à ce que nos territoires
les plus en tension
ne soient pas dépossédés
de leur force de l'ordre.
On observe à Mayotte
un blocage total
de l'île qui doit
nous alerter
et qui appelle
à de nouveaux renforts.
Sur les questions économiques,
beaucoup reste
à faire.
Un constat est partagé
par nos agriculteurs
et dirigeants
d'entreprise, celui
du poids des normes.
En 2017,
il était annoncé
que pour toute loi votée,
on en supprimerait deux.
Remettez cela à l'ordre du jour.
Simplifiez les normes
pour nos entreprises.
Arrêtons la surtranspositions
des normes.
Le monde de l'entreprise
et des agriculteurs alertent aussi
sur la difficulté
à transmettre l'activité.
Beaucoup d'agriculteurs
ont du mal
à transmettre leur exploitation.
Ils doivent pouvoir obtenir
des prix spécifiques
de carrière
sur 25 ans afin
d'avoir de la visibilité.
Nous avons besoin
d'objectifs clairs
sur l'installation des jeunes,
et leur rémunération
est nécessaire.
Enfin, c'est primordial:
n'importons pas
l'agriculture
que nous ne voulons pas
produire
chez nous.
Sortons les sujets agricoles
comme monnaie d'échange
de tous les accords
commerciaux
entre l'Union Européenne
et les pays tiers.
Il y a beaucoup d'autres
sujets à traiter,
mais le temps est court.
Enormément
de problématiques
sont sur la table.
Elles demandent
des réponses concrètes
et sans demi-mesure.
Nous serons exigeants.
Nous dirons
quand les réponses
nous paraissent déconnectées.
Notre groupe parlementaire
se montrera pragmatique
dans l'évaluation
des mesures proposées.
Dans un parlement
sans majorité absolue,
notre groupe sera
force de proposition
avec des réformes
concrètes à mener.
Nous espérons être entendus.
La situation politique
de notre pays
le commande.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur Christophe Naegelen.
La parole est à monsieur
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
pour 5 minutes.
- Nicolas Dupont-Aignan:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier ministre,
chers collègues.
Vous entrez dans le livre
des records,
non pas
parce que vous êtes le plus jeune
Premier
ministre,
mais parce que vous êtes le
nouveau Premier ministre
du président de tous
les tristes records.
Record d'endettement,
avec 788 milliards supplémentaires
depuis 2017.
Record de déficit
commercial, record
de déficit budgétaire,
record d'immigration,
record d'insécurité,
avec +63% de coups
et blessures
depuis 2017.
Bien sûr, record
d'impopularité,
parce qu'on ne peut pas
éternellement confondre
"présidence
de la République" et "agence
de communication".
Vous devez vivre dans le même
monde parallèle Emmanuel Macron
pour avoir osé,
cet après-midi,
qualifier son bilan
de "concret, tangible
et solide".
Je comprends mieux
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
vous a choisi.
J'attendais
un Premier ministre,
j'ai découvert un porte-parole.
Un seul discours
aura donc suffi
pour comprendre
que votre nomination
ne changera
rien,
et cela pour deux raisons
principales.
La première,
c'est que le président
Emmanuel Macron est le vrai
Premier ministre,
comme sa conférence
de presse l'a démontré.
Comment allez-vous conforter
les classes moyennes,
alors qu'Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
lui-même l'augmentation
des franchises
sur les médicaments,
et Bruno Le Maire,
l'augmentation
du tarif de l'électricité?
Dans le domaine
de l'Education nationale,
comment voulez-vous
pouvoir répondre
à toutes les demandes?
En matière d'insécurité,
comment faire baisser
la délinquance
en conservant un garde
des Sceaux et une politique
judiciaire profondément laxistes
et en étant fiers
de laisser détricoter
une loi sur l'immigration
déjà insuffisante?
Enfin, dans le domaine
du logement,
vous ne manquez pas de culot
pour annoncer
"un choc
de l'offre",
alors que depuis 2017,
vous avez systématiquement saboté
tous les mécanismes
d'aide au logement.
La seconde raison
pour laquelle
vous êtes condamné
à parler
dans le vide,
à agiter des éléments
de langage
éternellement ressassés
depuis 2017,
c'est que le vrai président
est malheureusement à Bruxelles.
Madame Ursula von der
Leyen vous donne
des ordres.
Preuve en est:
la Commission européenne vient
d'annoncer à l'instant
que les négociations
avec le Mercosur
allaient continuer.
Cela inflige
un nouveau camouflet
à l'Elysée,
qui prétendait hier
qu'elles seraient stoppées.
Au moment où vous prétendez
éteindre l'incendie agricole
en tenant un discours
sur une botte
de foin, on votait
en faveur de l'accord
de libre-échange
avec le Chili,
après ceux
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande,
le Kenya ou le Viêtnam.
Vous avez préféré
donner des gages
aux Allemands plutôt
que de baisser
le tarif de l'électricité
en sortant
du marché européen.
L'Espagne et le Portugal
ont su le faire.
Pour faire oublier vos doubles
discours successifs,
vous êtes condamné
à multiplier
les effets d'annonce.
Vous nous avez livré
cet après-midi
un catalogue de mesurettes.
Avant-hier, l'éducation
était au-dessus
de tout.
Hier, c'était l'agriculture.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le travail.
Vous me faites penser
à ces jongleurs d'assiettes
dans les cirques
qui sont obligés
d'en agiter toujours
plus pour tenir
en haleine le spectateur,
jusqu'au jour
où elles se brisent toutes.
Ce jour est proche.
Les Français
ne supportent
plus les fausses promesses,
les injonctions contradictoires,
le manque de sérieux
et de maturité
dans la conduite de l'Etat,
la disparition
de la souveraineté populaire.
Sans majorité politique,
vous serez obligé
de multiplier
jusqu'à plus soif
les 49.3.
ou plutôt une motion
de censure,
qui nous libérera
de cette mauvaise pièce
de théâtre, et les souffrances
des Français,
la nôtre et la vôtre
seront abrégés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Je ne serai pas très long.
Une partie
des interventions
qui ont succédé
à ma réponse
avaient déjà été écrites.
Je voudrais revenir
sur quelques points
qui m'ont semblé importants,
notamment s'agissant
de nos agriculteurs.
J'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire
tout à l'heure,
dans les tout prochains jours,
nous annoncerons
de nouvelles mesures
en soutien à nos agriculteurs.
Nous avons échangé
avec leurs représentants
pendant 3h30.
Des discussions
se poursuivent
entre eux et leurs équipes
pour avancer.
C'est attendu.
Je voudrais revenir
sur certains points
qui ont été évoqués.
Je voudrais dire à monsieur
Olivier Marleix que,
sur la question
des tourbières
et des zones humides,
j'ai annoncé
que je donnais
la consigne à l'ensemble
des préfets
de mettre ce travail
en pause le temps
de revoir les choses
avec les représentants
des agriculteurs.
Nous avons assumé
de présenter un projet
de loi.
Ca n'a pas été simple.
Je me souviens
des débats politiques
qui sont intervenus
dans cet hémicycle.
Nous avons assumé,
sur la betterave,
de réautoriser
les néonicotinoïdes,
car la filière
était en train de couler.
Les néonicotinoïdes
avaient été supprimés
sous la majorité
de François Hollande
sans que la majorité
s'occupe de savoir s'il
y avait des solutions
de substitution.
En 2017,
nous nous sommes rendu
compte qu'il n'y
avait pas de solution
de substitution.
Nous avons donc réautoriser
les néonicotinoïdes
pour la betterave.
J'assume de dire
que quand vous avez,
à l'initiative d'une agence,
une décision d'interdiction d'une
molécule sans se préoccuper
de savoir
ce qui se passe
au niveau européen,
c'est un problème.
J'assume de le dire.
Nous devons
regarder comment
nous avons une organisation
qui fonctionne mieux.
Sur Egalim, nous suivons
de très près, notamment
avec Bruno Le Maire,
les discussions
qui sont en cours,
notamment
sur le lait,
que vous avez évoquées.
Je voudrais rappeler qu'avant
les lois Egalim,
c'est la loi LME
qui s'appliquait
et qui donnait
les pleins pouvoirs
à la grande distribution.
Aucun agriculteur
ne m'a dit
que les lois Egalim
étaient un recul.
Ils nous disaient
qu'il fallait améliorer
le fonctionnement d'Egalim.
Il faut faire
davantage de contrôles
et prendre des mesures.
On en a parlé hier
avec les associations
d'agriculteurs.
Il faut des mesures
pour la rendre
plus efficace.
Sur les jachères,
cela fait des mois
que Marc Fesneau
est mobilisé auprès
de la Commission européenne.
Nous avons rallié
22 pays européens.
Je crois
que nous allons obtenir
cette semaine, j'ai vu
des signes positifs,
une nouvelle dérogation
sur le sujet.
Je veux dire
au Rassemblement National
et à madame
Le Pen,
puisque vous avez mis
en avant le sujet
des jachères
au Parlement européen,
que quand vous dénoncez
les nouvelles règles
sur les jachères,
elles sont issues
des nouvelles
règles de la PAC
que vos députés
au Parlement européen
ont votées.
Ils ont voté pour.
C'est la réalité.
Vous votez
les règles de la PAC
que vous critiquez,
mais vous ne votez
pas le budget de la PAC
que vous voulez.
C'est à se demander
si vos députés savent
ce qu'ils votent
au niveau européen.
C'est à se demander si vos députés
savent sincèrement
ce qu'ils votent.
La réalité,
c'est que vous nous parlez
de protection
et d'indépendance
de notre industrie.
Nous avons porté
au niveau européen
une taxe carbone aux frontières.
Cela faisait longtemps que,
dans l'industrie
en Europe, on se battait
pour une taxe carbone
aux frontières.
Vos députés ne l'ont pas votée.
Avoir de l'acier
chinois au même prix
que l'acier européen,
ça n'a pas l'air
de vous choquer.
Vous venez
nous déclarer ici
et dans les médias
qu'il faut relancer
nos exportations
et nos échanges internationaux,
tous nos accords de libre-échange.
Vous irez expliquer
à nos éleveurs
de porcs en Bretagne
qui exportent 30%
de leur production
et qui exportent
en Chine...
Quand un accord est bon
pour nos agriculteurs
et qu'il est suffisamment
protecteur
pour nos agriculteurs,
nous assumons
de le soutenir.
Quand un accord
est mauvais,
comme pour le Mercosur,
nous assumons
de nous y opposer.
Nous continuerons de le faire.
C'est ça, la cohérence.
Vous êtes totalement
contre tout qu'à
la fin, vous finissez
par ne plus défendre
les intérêts de notre pays.
Quand on propose
de soutenir l'Ukraine,
de sanctionner
les oligarques russes,
il ne faut pas compter
sur votre soutien
et celui de vos députés européens.
Je pourrais en parler
longuement,
mais je ne le ferai pas.
L'essentiel ici
est de redire l'engagement
qui est le nôtre
et celui du président
de la République en ce moment.
Ce sera
encore le cas jeudi
dans le cadre du Conseil européen.
Nous voulons faire
progresser les choses
au service de notre agriculture.
Evidemment que c'est difficile.
Evidemment
qu'il y a un certain nombre
de cas
où on ne peut pas convaincre
tout le monde.
C'est la difficulté.
La solution de facilité
est de s'opposer
à tout, comme vous.
Ca fait progresser quoi
pour nos agriculteurs?
Ca leur permet quoi?
Je me tourne aussi vers vous.
C'est aussi la solution
qui est la vôtre.
Vous avez là-dessus
une forme d'incohérence.
On continuera à se battre
pour nos agriculteurs.
Heureusement
que nous sommes là
pour accompagner nos agriculteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Le débat est clos.
Je vous propose
une suspension de 5 minutes.